in this course radu will teach you how
to think like a computer science
professor radu has a phd in computer
science he teaches computer science at a
university as well as on his youtube
channel in this course you will see
radu's thought process as he codes a
project for the very first time many
tutorials show you how to build a
project that the instructor has already
fully thought out beforehand but in this
video you will learn what really goes
into building a project from scratch and
he does it all without even referencing
the internet leave a comment with any
insights you learn from watching his
thought process
hi in this video you'll see how i made
this avatar using just vanilla
javascript and html canvas
i made this while competing with samwell
so
it wasn't scripted and we didn't even
know what project we're gonna do when we
began
so don't look at this as a tutorial
because i do a lot of mistakes in it
but i really think you should watch the
video
because it shows the thought process of
how to
solve a problem like this in the real
world and tutorials are not like that
tutorials just show
step-by-step instructions
of
solving a problem and those were usually
polished well before recording the
tutorial so if you really want to be a
better problem solver you should check
it out
so the project we're gonna do
is going to be
an avatar
i'm going to make something that kind of
looks like me and
maybe is able to talk or or something
let's see about that
and
i'm going to do this project in
html and javascript so it's going to be
like a web page
and i'm also going to do this without
using
any kind of
libraries
or
external code
so the reason i want to do this now
particularly
is because i'm going up against
somewhere and um
let's just say that i am about twice as
old as he is and even though i said i'm
not gonna be
pulling my punches
um
i think i need to set some additional
rules for myself
and these rules are going to be
[Music]
not to use other code this is something
i normally do when i make my tutorials
but in this case i'm going to definitely
try not to look at other code and
actually i'm not going to use
the internet i'm just going to try to
code this
using what i remember about coding in
javascript and
let's see how this goes so
i really think something like that is
needed but
having said that i won't
hold anything back so let's see how this
goes
i begin with
a simple html and
in the body part
i'm going to add the canvas
element
let's call it
my canvas
like this
and let me close the body
and
if you are watching this it means that
this video recording is pretty good
even though
this is unscripted and we just selected
this project a moment ago
so
i think it's good for you to watch a
video like this from time to time
because even though it's very long it
has something that normal tutorials
don't have and that's
showing how the thought process goes
when building something like this so
normally when you watch tutorials you
see people
doing something that they have done
before and they have made made it
previously and they just show you the
final steps most of the time
but you don't realize all the thought
that went into it and all the
experimentation and things like that
so
if you watch this now it means i decided
to post this video because i think it
has a lot of educational value in it
even though it's
far slower paced than my other
tutorials
so
hope you'll like it
now
i'm gonna also talk when i do these
things most of the time and
it's going to slow me down a bit but
i'm not going to talk normally like in
other tutorials
so
if it's something important that i'm
doing i will
explain more more carefully what that is
now
i refreshed the page here in the browser
on the right and i've actually opened
the index.html file that i started
defining here and you can see the
tab has changed its name there to the
title that i declared and the the canvas
is added here inside this page it's just
transparent and in the stop top region
so
let me start to
define some javascript next and
i'm going to do that here in a script
tag
i will use many external files at some
point but in the beginning i just want
to set up this html page somehow so i'm
going to get access to this
my canvas
let's just call it canvas
like this
and
i will set its width and height
let's say 300 pixels
many people also ask me
why do i disable the helper tools
from visual studio code
like it's not doing any autocompleting
for me or telling me if i have typos or
things like that and that's mostly
because when i do tutorials i want them
to not interfere with what i'm coding at
the moment so
often those windows just block parts of
the code that i might be explaining and
it's not very good from a pedagogical
standpoint
so let me give also a style here to the
canvas otherwise it's still transparent
and we can't see it there
so
i'm gonna say that the canvas is going
to have a
border of one pixel
solid and black
like this and if i refresh
now i see the canvas element
here
so
let me also align this to
center actually i'm going to keep it in
the top left corner i i prefer it like
that and i will remove this extra margin
from here it's going to make some things
easier
as we go
so let's say here margin zero
and now you can see this canvas over
there
okay
now
on this canvas i'm going to draw a
character and i'm going to make this
character a procedural object so it's
going to be drawn using mathematics and
lines and curves and different kind of
shapes and colors and things like that
but i'm going to
um a drawing i made of myself a long
time ago which i'm using to
brand my my channel as a as a reference
so i add it now here
inside of this
visual studio code
project
and i'm going to actually draw this
image this jpeg
on the canvas for reference to begin
with and then the lines that i'm going
to draw are going to be things that
define this
this character here
so let me
go back here and get a reference to the
context for drawing on the canvas and
that will be
get context and i'm going to be using
this 2d context
let's see if i have enough time and
energy to make this avatar even 3d a
little bit
but
at the moment
ideas are plenty and
i should stick to simple things and have
something that works first and then
expand somehow it's not not easy
so with the context i'm going to draw
the image
uh
draw image
method
uh
i need to get the image first so let me
get the image by saying
[Music]
new image and the source of this
image is going to be me dot jpg it's
here in the same directory
and i'm going to draw this
image
at
0 0
coordinates
on the canvas so if i refresh now
nothing happens
let me try to give this a width and a
height of
canvas width and canvas height
now
so for some reason this doesn't work
let's see
is the image existing in memory
yeah that should be there
so here i'm getting the context and i
have the image and i'm
drawing the image
maybe
actually you don't have to specify the
location there let's see
now
oh what is wrong
so the image is there
but if i try to draw it
it doesn't appear on the canvas
what if i just want to put it in the
background of the canvas canvas um style
no i can't do that
okay
so
it actually exists and it's there but
for some reason drawing it on the canvas
doesn't work
why
okay so three arguments required
i don't remember exactly
all the
all the parameters for this method
can i draw anything else on this canvas
let's see
ctx
move to
begin path
ctx move to
zero zero ctx
line to
300 300
and ctx stroke
okay so the line is just fine but then
ctx draw image
img
i think this should draw it
starting at the zero zero coordinate
there so something is strange
a tough start apparently i don't
remember simple things like this even
so
canvas works and it's initialized
properly but when i want to draw it
it doesn't appear there so what are the
arguments here
if i just put a draw image it says that
it needs
two more arguments
so
can i get the hint of what is this
of what methods are available draw image
not very useful
oh boy
how can i have problems with things like
this now i'm getting worried
so
there's no internet thing
it's scaring me right now
but
something here needs to work so what is
the problem
it is the correct name of the function i
saw it here when i looked at the
functions available here
so if i type here for example
ctx draw image without calling it
it shows his native code so it i can't
inspect it
at least i don't know how
oh here i get some information so x y
width and height
oh okay
there are multiple versions of this so
one it's with the x and y and you
specify also width and height so it
should work
with zero zero and
for example 100 100
what
why does this
ah
the image is not loaded
the image is not loaded i tried to draw
it
before the image had the time to load
horrible start so
uh
now it works it's a small image there
let's just put it here to be
[Music]
canvas
width and
canvas
height
like so
and i don't need this line
line 2 anymore this code right here
phew i really started to be worried
there for a moment now before i draw
this i actually want to draw it
transparent so global alpha set to 0.1
and
then i'm gonna reset global alpha to one
afterwards
uh two transparent maybe
four
okay and now i'm going to try to draw
this shape
using
using lines and curves and things like
that and i will start with the head
but before i start guessing these
coordinates is going to be horrible
really
so let's me
i'm going to write some code that helps
me take coordinates by clicking with the
mouse first so i'm going to say
canvas
uh
add event listener
mouse
down
actually
click i think it's better
let's see if it works and um
get
chord minutes
like this so a function for get chords
uh with the event
like this and let's just uh
log here
edt.x and evt
dot y to see if the coordinates are
correct
and uh refresh this and now when i click
this
i'm getting
0 close to 0 0 in this corner
close to 300 300 in that corner so
clicking gives me the coordinates from a
point that i
clicked on there so this is going to be
very useful
and let me just prepare here a function
called
draw
me
for now
code will become much better later when
i
figure out all the things i want to do
with this so i'm going to figure out the
end result of this
avatar as i'm making it
it's
gonna depend on
the things that i know how to do and
also
um the time that i have and things like
that i have a meeting in about
two hours a little after two hours over
two hours so
let's see if i continue after that so
draw me
here is going to be
called after the image is loading and
after i'm drawing it here on the canvas
so here for example i could draw the
head
let's draw just a line first from this
point right here to this point right
here so these are the coordinates that
i'm going to use
i'm going to say ctx
begin path
um
like that ctx move to
149
34
and ctx line
to
151
two two zero
like this
ctx stroke
like this
and now if i refresh i'm gonna get a
vertical line here like that so
um you can see that this code is helping
me so that when i click on the screen
i get the coordinates and i don't have
to guess these points
by
trial and error
and of course i can
fine tune these points for example i
probably know that this should be
actually 150 150 which is the middle of
this
canvas there so now the line is
perfectly straight before it was a
little bit off center because i made
mistakes in my licking
normally you want mistakes when you draw
things like that because something with
not perfect symmetry and
if it looks a little bit different on
one side than the other then the end
result is better
but
for this first part i'm gonna stick to
it like this
and at the end we'll see about
normalizing these coordinates somehow so
we'll get to that hopefully
okay so this kind of works let me reduce
this transparency
i mean make it even more transparent
maybe
like this
okay i kind of like that
thing right here
uh
okay
so i have just one line let's add a new
line to see also the width of the head
here
so
something like this
yeah i used 130 because i want it to be
perfectly horizontal here like so
and 75
to 15 i think that these are
proper pretty much
so here i just want them to be on the
other side of this 150 if
this is going to be symmetric
and i think it's actually not so 150
minus
75 it's
75 150
plus 75 is
225
so
let's
make this
fix it a little bit already
so now you can see already that the
initial drawing that i made of this
avatar was not perfectly symmetrical and
maybe i want it to be symmetrical at
least for now
okay
but
this is now somehow centering the head
right there
uh let's draw the shape of the head
somehow
so i'm gonna begin a new path
and i'm going to draw a line
from
this point right here to this point
right here next
move to
150
34.
and
75
1 3 0.
okay but this line is going to be curved
somehow so actually i'm not gonna use
line two here
i'm gonna use um
quadratic
curve
to
that point but for the quadratic curve i
need to give a control point
somewhere
maybe somewhere here 80 46 let's try
that
okay this is pretty much
what i would expect the
head to look like there
but i have a feeling that this quadratic
curve is not good because it's going to
give me pointy
pointy things there
um when i'm gonna
mirror this on the other sides
but actually
even if it's well let's just try
so i'm gonna do another quadratic curve
too and let's add the control point
here
like
94
and
196
and then the end point is going to be
this bottom one so 150 to 20.
i should actually label these points as
well so here if you can look it's a
little bit pointy but eventually this is
going to get covered by all this hair so
i don't need to worry if it's not so
perfect there so having this now i'm
going to actually
copy this
on
the right side
and i don't really like these numbers
they are becoming way too difficult to
somehow
calculate all the things so
i'm not going to do anything anymore at
this stage i'm actually going to scale
this
canvas so that
the center point is going to be here so
this is going to become the new 0 0
coordinate and everything else is going
to be
symmetric like this point is symmetric
to that but with minus and plus and the
minus and plus here also
um yeah let me do that so i'm going to
say here
[Music]
not there but here
ctx
scale
[Music]
um
okay
and um
ctx
translate
actually maybe i think this should be
first and i'm gonna translate to
canvas with divided by two
canvas height divided by 2.
so
now things stopped working at the moment
but it's ok
let's see if this can
be fixed somehow
so we translate it to the middle of the
canvas and we also scaled let's um
not scale for the moment so yeah we
translate it there but now this has to
start at
minus canvas with divided by two
and minus canvas height divided by two
okay
if we scale
like that
then i think this now needs to be just
one divided by two one divided by two
one
and one
um actually
yeah
i think it's something like this
yeah i did some mistake here i want to
scale it up so that
these values mean what i want them to
mean but actually um
i think i want to scale it like this
sorry by
half
by half because i don't want to work
with these half values here i actually
prefer
i think to work in the space from
minus one to plus one so
now when i'm drawing this this corner up
here means
uh
minus one
yeah it means minus one minus one and
this one on the right is going to mean
plus one plus one i have to fix also
this get coordinates there
but uh also these ones so
this now means
zero
yeah
so all these coordinates i actually want
to
subtract
150
and
divide by
150
so a little bit work to do here but it's
going to make the numbers easier to work
with afterwards you'll see
so
the 150s become zero
zero zero
zero
and then
three four minus one fifty
077 with the minus
then
220 minus 150
46
like that
then
[Music]
75
and i actually know that this one is
going to be plus 0.5
because it was symmetric to begin with
and this 130
minus
0.13
okay
so
i think this is correct
and i can replace also these ones
and
this 75 was actually
this one i think
i'm gonna need new
new coordinates for that let me just
comment out these
oh
interesting something happened
happened
i'm not drawing any fill i think what
happens is that the
line with
yeah the line with is very very
thick now because of that scaling i did
previously so actually i would like to
do the stroke
or let me just ctx line with
something very small and work with that
okay i think this is
just fine now
and for these i'm gonna need new
coordinates and i rewrite that but after
i fix this part right here so i want
this to log
the x
minus
canvas
width divided by two
and then
divided by canvas
width
divided by two so something like that
this is going to now give me
the coordinates when i click on the
canvas
so that
it's already scaled in this new space
that i'm dealing with so this one here
should be close to minus 1 1
this one here
one one
and this
thing in the middle should be
pretty much zero zero
like this and um
i don't want this log to be so ugly
so
uh let's just calculate here
x is equal to this
and um
around this so
maybe this works
if i remember right
so the number formatting
method here if i put two
at the second argument it's going to
give me
just two decimal place
i think it's probably gonna be enough
and this is gonna be x and y here
so
why
oh number format is not a function how
was this
not format too fixed
i think so
too fixed
i don't remember where the two fixed
ease
yeah i don't remember how this works
anymore
i don't think there is a thing called
format so no
number
oh no uh i think this is the number
yeah let's just leave here
um
something like that
and um i just copied this one for the y
as well
and here x two fixed yeah just two
decimals
so it is a number already and it's a
method from the number
yeah now it works and it looks
it looks quite good
okay so what were these control points
here the one
on the top
minus
minus
0.44 minus seven one and the bottom one
that
but these coordinates here need to also
be
0 and 0.46
so
ok what did i do wrong
this one
needs to be this one
great so we have the same thing as
before but uh
different so why did i do all this crazy
stuff it's just that now and i want to
make this symmetric on the other side as
well i'm going to
copy this for example
and
this one is going to go to
this point
right here but the control point is
going to be the same as this one but
with the plus here because now this
control point is somewhere here and plus
will make it go somewhere there so i
don't need to do so much mental
calculations if everything is symmetric
like that
and uh let's just do the final one here
as well so we're gonna go back to the
beginning to this
coordinate there and this control point
will have a plus right here so
it's it took some extra time i didn't
prepare for this kind of thing but
it works so great
okay
now uh this is the shape of the head
a little bit
and
i am soon going to have to specify names
for these points i think let's
let's see i might define some points for
these so that i can animate them if i'm
going to move the head in some way that
would be nice
but
let's see
so now that we have this
i can also draw the body a little bit so
let's draw the neck here
so these two chords in its
begin
path
and
let's just say move to
this location
and
align to
this
location i think i want this console log
here to output the comma between the
points as well
so
let me concatenate here a comma
like this
for the future
oh i have this horrible thing here
all right
so we have the neck there
good but the neck is a little bit curved
it's supposed to be a little bit curved
if you look
closely
and i'm gonna do that as well so i'm
going to say here
quadratic curve to the same destination
but i will add the control point maybe
somewhere here
so this is going to be like that and now
the comma is also here so i
quicker at debugging and now the neck is
curved like this it's great
[Music]
so it's going like that
and
let's continue this path to make the
body somehow
so
add another point right here
and i think i'm just going to
line to
this one
so let me
copy this
like so
now it's just fine i'm not going to
focus on that part of the body very much
and clothes are gonna cover that
eventually
so
it's perfect
and uh
let's now
make it go off the screen a little bit
so downwards like the shoulder from here
same x but a y that is going to be
one or more let's put it 1.1 so this is
going to go now
down off screen a little bit and i'm
going to do the same to the right so
the next line two is gonna be
a plus here
uh we don't see it but now it's
somewhere there
and uh this one is gonna be
with a plus there
like that
and
now we are going to go
to
this location but with the plus
so let me
do that
and finally
a quadratic curve to for the other side
of the neck we are going to this
location but with the plus right here
because it's on the other side of the
center
and the the control point it's going to
be also symmetric so it has also a plus
there
great
so
let me actually extract this draw me
function for from here and say that this
is going to be the body
i think eventually i'm going to use
object-oriented
programming
but um
i just want to see if it's needed and
get something done and then i will
refactor at some point so now i'm
drawing the body and then the head
so let me
refactor this one as well
draw
head
okay and i'm gonna put the body before
drawing the head because
i want these lines here to be covered
with whatever the head will look like
okay i'm missing a begin path somewhere
or no
uh no this line width has to happen
early on i'm gonna just set the line
width somewhere at the top for now
so all the lines will be like this
this shape
this size
all right
now
i would like the head to
let's
still practice a little bit with these
lines or
no
no i would like the head to actually
rotate a little bit so let's think how
we can do that so i want
him to be able to
turn his head like saying no for example
left or right i think that without doing
some fancy feature like this uh i'm not
gonna win this challenge so just drawing
this
you could just replace this with the
sprite so
i want this to have more personality
than that
so
if we consider a point here
in the center
maybe the nose
could be considered the center
of the
somehow let's see
so
um
let's just consider this center point
for now and give it a name
let me
actually
draw this point somehow so i'm going to
make a function
draw a point
let's give it the label
and
this is going to be
ctx begin path
ctx
arc
uh we need the location for this one as
well not just the label
so
location.x location.y
and
a radius
let's set here a radius with the value
of 0.01
or something like that
and
pass this radius
and the arc method needs 0 and math dot
pi times 2 so
2 pi means
360 degrees a full circle
and now i'm going to do this
and that point here is actually a point
let's see draw
point
it's point um
zero on the
x
but vertically it's uh minus zero 0.13
this is where i drew this line because
it's where the head is the widest i
somehow want to have that value for
i feel i want to have that value
so
we might change many of these things
later but let's see how this draw point
method looks like
so
refresh nothing happens
because
i'm not giving
the point in the proper way
maybe
yeah let's give it in the proper way
like this
x and y i think it's fine
okay and it's actually here but very
small let's make this radius
bigger
yeah i think that's fine and the ctx
feel
but
let's give it the white fill color
so
ctx
fill style
is white
and
after i fill it i want to draw there a
label so this
let's call this point
a
so the label a
and i'm going to say here ctx
fill text
label
at
location.x and location.y
like this but before that i will change
this to black so that we can see black
and white
oh boy it's a horribly big
font
let's give it a radius
number of
pixels
and make it aerial
i somehow like this font for some reason
and uh
i wonder if text works well in this
scaling conditions
but um okay what what happens here
let's put 0.1 pixels
i think that it might not
work for some reason this feels
filled text
the scaling method that i have
used here might affect somehow the
the text properties and i don't know if
it supports these
number of pixels
or does it but
i i didn't concatenate this pixel value
here
let me
yes okay phew
i
i don't need to use a space there
it's uh
linked to that value okay a radius of
a size of maybe radius times two
now it's too small
i think that is something fine
maybe
okay but
i need to do
text align
center
like this
okay and now point a is in the center
there so this point a i want to be able
to control somehow
let me
make the background here actually
light green
and remove the stroke from here i think
it's somehow too many strokes and i
don't want it to be so distracting
i think that's fine
or let's make this green
and the field style is going to be
white
i think this is much much more readable
and this radius can be a little bit
smaller maybe 1.9
i just want to have things here that
look somehow nice
since i'm gonna reuse this component
multiple times i might as well
have some nice components to work with
that is not distracting in some way
okay for some reason this
would need a little bit of adjustment
here as well and i want to use part of
the radius
for that so that this is
relatively
well
implemented so that if i change some of
these
scaling properties it looks good okay
so
this point a is something that i want to
control somehow
and i'm going to define for this some
slider
let me try to do that input type
range
id
a
the x of that point will be controlled
by this ax
slider
okay
so we have the slider now here
uh
i would like it to be up here actually
so um
no i don't want that because it's gonna
mess up with my
cord and it's when i click on the screen
i don't want to bother with that i'm
actually gonna
put this
slider i want it up because i will have
more of them
so let's put here
sliders eventually i i want to move that
point maybe also upwards let's see so
another slider for that
and um
i want this sliders element to be
uh
positioned at the top somehow so
not the best way to do this i might
redesign the things later but let's see
zero
okay now it's here but i want it to be
left
300
pixels okay
so this slider is going to control
our position and
for this ax element and let's just say
that
we will give here a minimum value of
minus one
max
plus one
okay and initially it's it's zero by
default
okay so
now
on change
uh
unchanged i'm going to
set here a value
a function for
update
point probably we'll rename this
soon
let's see but the update point
let's put here info and log this
info in the console because i don't
remember what it contains so now when i
change this
okay it only works when i
release so i don't really want that
uh i think there exists also on
update
no
on drag
no
one change
but really i
am pretty sure that
it's on update
with
small u or
no i don't think it matters
on
change
yeah i really want it to go while i'm
dragging this so this on change
is not enough
on move
no
update
these are so different in different
programs and different languages i don't
remember
ah
on
no i don't remember
let's just leave it like this for now
so
what i want to print in the console is
not the whole info but
i think it's value
oh
but why is it like that because i
specified here one as the maximum
okay now it works but
i can only put one zero or minus one it
snaps somehow i think there is a step
also
that can be used to fine tune this
yeah okay
i guess i can work with this
oh and i can use the keyboard
to
to move this as well
okay so now the thing is
i want this slider to control how the
head is going to rotate
by first controlling where this point is
going to be
relative to that and
this is between -1 and 1 so it's going
to be a
maximum
100 percent or negative 100 percent
movement that we will allow in the
interface
so
let's just define this a point somewhere
i'm going to define
it at the top somewhere maybe
maybe here
a is equal to
something
so this in the beginning
and then i'm just gonna write there a
for now
so
this point is here
and
when we move this slider i want a
according to this to go
left on the x
or right on the x so this would be left
on the x from this original location
uh like mid location to the far left and
far right extremities that we will give
so
this x and y is like the initial
like center
point
the only thing i'm changing is the x
right
so it's like the initial initial
location but then um
let's call another
property here x
range
between
let's say minus zero point
[Music]
seven
now zero point two something small and
plus zero point two so this is gonna be
an array
of two elements for this x range
so now what we are doing
[Music]
updating the point i'm going to say
a dot
x is going to be
within that x range give me the value
according to this
percentage here so this is between minus
100 percent plus hundred percent
and maybe center
could be somewhere
in the middle
i really want these things to be
symmetric so putting here things like
that is kind of too much
let's just try to put center point and
there and if the value is negative it's
gonna mirror itself to the left if that
makes sense so i'm only putting things
on the right of this center part and
everything else becomes symmetric to the
left with the minus minus values
so ax is going to be
i'm going to do linear interpolation so
linear interpolation between
a dot x
range
of 0
and a dot x range of
1.
using this value as the percentage
so
function
linear interpolation is very simple you
have just two values let's call them a
and b
or start and end
and a percentage we can call that
t because p usually stands for point so
the function is really easy it's
you take the first value and you add the
difference between
the end and the start multiplied by this
t value so
if t is zero
then this whole thing is zero and you're
just at the starting point
if t is one
then this difference is going to the
minus s from here
i mean if t is one this disappears and
the minus s from here cancels this one
so you're just left with the end point
if this is somewhere in the middle then
this difference is not going to amount
as much so it's basically evenly spacing
you
values according to this percent here
and if this t is
negative
this difference from here actually goes
uh on the up other side so i expect that
this will work with the negative values
as well so let me just
try this
like that but
[Music]
i
won't see any changes here if i'm
dragging this because
i'm not redrawing this on every frame i
need to animate this
so
i'm going to put this draw me function
inside the function called animate
that
i'm going to call draw me
on every frame
and the
request
animation frame is the method that
does this calling of the animate
function again and again and again as
fast as it can
so now
it still doesn't work
oh because i'm not calling the animate
function anywhere but where am i calling
draw draw me okay
so
animate here once the image is loaded
okay
something bad happens because
yeah
um
it just draws again and again and again
thinks on the canvas so i think i'm
going to copy this drawing of the image
every time we draw us i also draw the
reference image this image by the way
will disappear
by the end so that's no
not something that will stay here and
now it's drawing it on top of each other
with these kind of uh
small alphas there
it looks horrible i will just
clear
clear the canvas
i hope this works
uh no it doesn't because
we are in this new space right now so i
need to use
this
okay so it looks as before but now every
time i release here that a point is
actually going to
change according to my slider
um
within this
um
range that i allow it so i told it
basically that it can go from
zero which is somewhere here
to
0.2 which is somewhere there
but
because linear interpolation works also
with the negative
value for t that we can give with this
slider i can also have symmetrical
symmetric behavior there as well
which is good
i think
i'm not entirely sure
i don't want everything to be symmetric
but some things i i want them to be
symmetric so
yeah so now that i have this a point
there
i'm going to
try to draw
this straight line that we had
previously to be controlled by a
in some way like using a as a control
point
so that the head tends to rotate
rotate a little bit like that
so let's see if we can get that to work
a is now here
and
when we draw the head this is the
vertical line here
and uh i don't want it to be
uh line two anymore i want it to be a
quadratic curve to
where
the end point is the same it's this one
at the bottom right there
but the first point here is going to be
a dot x a dot y
so
instead of the line two we have a
quadratic curve
that goes through a
when a is there it looks like a straight
line but if i'm gonna do this
you can see the head tends to
rotate
at least a little bit
influenced by that control point so this
quadratic curve two function it's
actually poorly named because there's
also another function called
bezier curve two that has two control
points and it's poorly called i think
because both of them are bezier curves
bezier curves are very general curves
and they can have
infinitely many control points so you
can have one two three
there is no
function in the canvas with three points
but you could implement it yourself
using
bernstein polynomials or something like
that
but um
yeah so both of them are
um
bezier curves so the fact that there is
another one called bezier curve 2 means
that this one
would not be
which is kind of
i don't know bad naming but
when dealing with bezier curves it
doesn't mean that the curve is going to
pass through that point so this is one
thing that people are usually confused
about what it means is that when you
start the curve here in the beginning
you start exactly in the direction of
this point so if you draw a tangent from
this point it would go through a
but it's just influenced and as you're
going the end point starts to influence
as well so you don't actually pass
through a over there
uh if my math is right i think that if
you put here instead of ax
ax times 2
then it goes through a because when you
have these quadratic curves
essentially what i'm doing now is
my control point here it's a x times 2
so it's somewhere here where my mouse is
now
and then the curve goes exactly through
that value so
the
point where
let me just undo this
the point
where
the curve will pass through closest to
this a is actually gonna be halfway
between where a is and
the
straight line
goes
there so a little bit of math this might
be helpful later when i'm gonna do some
of these
things more carefully but okay this is
the a x somehow
how about one for the a y as well
so
i want to make this line here the
straight line there also modified by a
slider like that so let me go here in
our sliders and define a y in exactly
the same way as previously
and here it's something that i really
want to change
something
so this update point
um
i really want to say that this is uh
just the x element
x attribute needs to change and this one
has to change its y attribute i don't
really like this function here let's see
later if it becomes better but
now update point
attribute so the attribute
a of x so this here
i can also write it like this and it
should work
but now instead of that hard coded
string i'm going to put here the
attribute is going to be
um
not very good
uh i think what we will do is um
so i want the y range as well
let's say
0 and
0.4
just to test and to see that they are
different but i need to be able to
specify
where i want these
this interpolation to happen so now this
attribute
yeah let's just
say here for now switch based on the
attribute
and the
case x then
a of x
is equal to
that
break
and
a of
y
is gonna be with y range here so i
wanted to do this with a single line but
i think this is also
clear at least for now let's see later
what what happens
if this kind of code structure is good
so what happens now we have two sliders
and this other one controls the movement
vertically somehow
but
there is a problem here because
zero point is not where this
thing is
from previously
and uh maybe this is actually a good
thing
um
let me think about that
but uh of course i could change this so
this
line this horizontal line here it's um
at this location
so if i'm going to
put
the y range
like that
then 0 is is fine there but
let me
try to have these steps more fine for
this one
i have a feeling there is something
wrong with the math here so let me just
move this with my
keyboard
no it looks pretty good so with my
keyboard a is moving
yeah it's it's moving quite well
i don't know why i expect it to be a
jump there somewhere let me try to make
this even smaller
it looks quite smooth there
yeah okay everything seems to be just
fine yeah it's uh it's good the math is
good
i
don't know why i thought different
so
so
with a there
this looks good now but the horizontal
line should be now controlled by a
and
let's do it so that
i do the same kind of quadratic curve to
here
going
to the bottom so from the top to the
bottom
and um
[Music]
the same control point as uh
previously a a controls both of those
curves
so now
you can see somehow the head
seemingly
3d ish
but
some things here i just don't like for
example
i actually want those curves to go
through a
but that's not gonna be so easy to do i
think
let me see
i don't want
necessarily this to happen and i don't
think that it will happen exactly
yeah
i don't want
actually to complicate it like that but
horizontally i think the movement is
good but vertically
it's way too much so when i wrote here
at the top
um
the y range going
from
this to that this this value is just too
much way too much so i'm gonna put here
maybe also 0.2 as the other one let's
see now how it looks like
so
left
right
and
like that
and this one here
still too much i don't want to
have so exaggerated movement i just want
to give a little idea of 3d this is not
going to be a
3d space with x y and z it's just going
to be some locations
like some keyframes when the character
is looking left when the character is
looking right and then interpolating
between those
somehow so
it's one technique that
is used in animation quite quite often
but here i'm coding it instead which is
actually not very often
in practice
so
up and down it's actually way too much
i'm gonna put here maybe point one
i think this is just
great so good enough movement there and
the left and right
yeah something like that
so question is
yeah okay
and then the things that will somehow uh
color the face and give it hair and
things like that will
also be influenced in the same way as
this a point
somehow so that would be
overall the
idea
there are a few things that i don't like
yet for example moving your head up
doesn't just
rotate it
like this
if i can try to mimic this
your head actually moves a little bit
upwards so
these points here
and this point here should also be
affected by these sliders
otherwise it just looks very
robotic
and
not very
realistic and same goes for left and
right
when i especially left and right because
you can see the chin is
really going off from the the center of
the of the body when you do that
so
these points need to have
ranges
as well as this uh a point that we are
somehow now i'm considering this a point
as a point that the character is looking
at
if it's
quite in in front of
in front of the character so
it has some sliders there
uh to control that but the whole head
shape is going to be affected
uh as well not just this center point of
the face it's uh
yeah so that's what we are going to try
to do next and i'm going to define these
points
give them labels as well as a is here so
let's see uh i'm going to name this
point
maybe b
b c d e or something like that
so let's define these points as well
and
um
i'm just going to start with one of the
points
maybe
b
and this one is going to be
this location from here the first move
to that we do there so i'm going to cut
this say here b dot x b dot y
and
put the values here so 0 and minus 0.77
and there is going to be also
a range for x
we will figure what the out what
what those are
what that is
and also a y for that
but let's just put these values to be
minus
0.77
minus 0.77 so essentially the range is
null
and 0 0 so now x is between 0 and 0 and
y is between minus 77
minus 77 so there's no range there i
just put it as a default value
so just to get it to appear somewhere
first
and uh let's put also b
b
like that
so b is there
the sliders don't affect b
at the moment at all
because also
this draw point is something
i mean update point is something that
only updates point a
so
not
good code here i really need to think
about this just in a second
but uh before that this b is
0 and minus 0.77
let's see if these points
are
still somewhere
so this is b right here definitely
i think those are the only ones this one
here and this one here so let's just put
there bx by
and uh now in this update point function
i need to be able to specify somehow
which is the point so
let's
put here b that that's the point i want
to modify i send it as a parameter like
that
sorry first one is is a actually
okay
and here in the update point i could say
um
point so which one is going to be
but now i need the way to access this so
we could put actually all of these
inside of um an object
called
points
maybe live points they are points that
move
and
this object is going to have an
attribute
called a
and an attribute called b i don't know
if this is better yet but
i need to
update the code depending on what i am
looking and feeling when i'm designing
this so this is not the typical
waterfall way of developing things it's
quite agile and you think
what you need to change according to
what you want to achieve there
so
now life points actually
and the every time
i'm using
a or b
like this
or um i could actually destructure this
i think and have uh references for a and
b
let's see const
a b is equal to
live
points
maybe does this fix my problem
life points is not iterable
no not not that so
huh
this is not an array
okay a is still moving even though i did
this change right here
but then i want in the update point
to take
not a here
but
the
live points
let's call this
point p is
live points
of point which is a string so this point
here is a string and
it's specified here which point are we
changing by the slider
let's actually also have
here a and b like labels so that we
oh no no no no no no it's not a and b
it's a x oh boy
a x a y
no what am i doing this is not not even
a anymore
let's just keep team these a
x and y so this id here it's actually
not used anywhere
um
but this is not update point it's it's
update points now
yes it's update points now all the
points need to update according to
the value of these sliders and this
slider controls the x and the other one
controls the y
so
let me
even remove this id from here because
it's confusing now and we don't seem to
need it
so what we do now is go through all the
live points so
and
and each of them have their own ranges
right
so
this is now update points
and
um
for each point
in there i'm going to switch depending
on the attribute
and um
p dot x
so at first it's going to be a and then
it's going to be
b
and both of them have a range on x and
the range and y
and
the the ranges will eventually be
different so let's see if this code
works
okay some problem there
haha
um
for for each
[Music]
this would need to be an array i think
let's see how the four in
loop
for
let be
in
live points
i really don't remember all of the ways
that these
for loops work but
okay
so
um this is
point id like a in that case and here
i'm gonna say
the point
p is gonna be
live points of
p id so i don't use array but
yeah okay so x is okay
y is okay let me just add the line break
there at the top
okay and uh i think they can be a little
bit to the right so
something like that
too much
okay
great
so
so let's try now to modify this b as
well so
it code should work we just have to
change these ranges here like if i'm
going to put a 0.02 range for b
you can see b is moving now
in that same kind of
as much as a is moving actually and all
the lines connected to b
are also adapting
according to the control points the same
control points that we had earlier and
you can see the shape here is not great
it's not like a real head would look
like but i have some other ideas for
drawing the head on top of that and i
think it's going to be fine
but one thing is i do want b to somehow
move like that but not as much so maybe
i'm going to put here 0.1
and now when a is going in that way b is
moving
b is moving
less so
i don't really know if b needs to move
like that
honestly
because the top of the head does stay in
the same place
but uh
i think i i do want it to move
vertically with the y
so it could be that i'm gonna just put
here range zero zero
like that or something very very small
sometimes
small values
uh make a big difference in how
everything feels so it may not seem like
something but it does so now i'm not
really doing any 3d stuff or
realistic movement is more like using
animation principles and
things like that to make the
movement more
appear organic to somebody who knows
some kind of things about about
drawing
drawing objects there and i'm not i
don't want anything to be perfect but
to look good so
many things are like that especially in
animation
um
you exaggerate and you emphasize some
things that don't normally happen in the
real real world
okay so let's try the vertical one as
well so from this
value here
let's give it
a value of
minus 8
0.8 and just see what happens
uh
okay it's it's opposite this
it's opposite
yeah it's opposite so
i want
0.7 there
so now that b point is also updating but
it's too much maybe
0.772 i just want a little bit of head
lowering
when
the character is looking downwards so
again a little bit goes a long way
and uh
same for the
upwards position
maybe
7.3
is actually even better
yeah i'm i'm happy with that
okay and
it's also supporting this a little bit
okay
now this chin this is
something that moves much more because
it's pointing out like like like
what
chins do
so let's try to do that point next and
uh
it's
this one right here so let's extract
point
c dot x
c dot y
and
i'm just going to
duplicate this line here
with
c
and
there is a plus value here 0 46
and the ranges
um again i'm going to start
or let's give this a value let's
actually make it two because
center of the face and the chin kinda
are on the same
plane i think
uh and the y range
yeah
um
zero point
46
and let's just give this
let's keep it like this for now and
modify it later so the c point
see
appears there
with 0 and 046
but it also appears
here
is this the only place where the chin
appears
how is it possible because
um okay we're drawing this way so
then we don't have to move to yes okay
so it's only one time here c dot x c dot
y
and an error
c is not defined because here where we
where i'm doing this destructuring
so that i do have
easy access for this a b and c points
and i don't have to always write
live points dot
a b c so
this destructuring is something i'm
probably going to forget very often but
now we have a b
b
c
abc
and yeah
you can see that a and c are somehow c
is definitely looking more like a like a
chin now when you're rotating and i'm
really happy with this i think
i like this shape of the head that we
have now
okay
and vertically
c is not moving and this is something
that needs to change
i think it should move similar to a
the place that you are looking in in
your
face yeah i think it should move
as much as a
pretty much let's see so a is moving
okay quite much
let's try to put here
60
six
it's
too much i think it's
not horrible
but
let's just put 62.
so the thing is
because these are on a plane
the bottom part
shouldn't move as much
as the top part
so this is a bit of a problem we are
having now
i like how it looks like when the face
is looking upwards because the chin
tends to let the neck visible and this
part from here
but um when it's i mean this position
but when it's going downwards
this becomes way too pointy like the
chin actually disappears between under
the nose and doesn't
expand doesn't expand that much
so i have a problem here this whole way
of doing things just doesn't seem to
work properly
in this case
i could do something of a
two ranges
a negative y range
and a positive
range
maybe we try to do that it won't be very
realistic but
we see if there are consequences
why negative range so this is going to
be
to zero point let's say
40.
and
here where we are doing these updates we
check to see
if the value is less than zero
very complicated stuff
so
let's say
const
value
is
if the info value is less than zero
no no no no
no
i want the x range i want the y range so
y range to use if the value is less than
zero then use
then use
negative range
otherwise
range
um
y
range i don't like what i'm doing now
but
at least to get something that works and
then we'll think about restructuring a
bit later
so
here i just take that value
and um
and
this only in the case that negative
range exists
so if
b dot y negative range
because all the other points are working
just perfectly now
so the only issue i have now is because
of the phase and the 3d
way that faces look like i can't model
this mathematically with such simple
linear interpolation techniques it needs
to behave differently when
when going up then when going down
um
so let's say here let y range
and the
value
and now this y range is going to be
that
so
actually y range equals to
that
but if the negative range exists then
it's going to change and value is going
to be info dot value
but here if the negative range exists
we actually want the value to be
the
absolute value
of the value i think i will
see if this works
okay what happened
did anything happen so let me put the
negative range that just doesn't change
so
something like this
okay
everything is opposite
oh
yes because y goes downwards so
uh
the range let's just keep it
46 and this one
62.
actually
62-46
so
and then
46 minus 16 30. so this is actually 0.3
here
okay so upwards movement is fine
but then downwards movement
at some point c becomes
i really want to use some kind of a
mathematical function like
the sign here
i don't know how to code this so nicely
and i don't know if
so much work is needed
but um okay so at least now c is
stationary there for the positive values
so what i'm gonna do next is um
modify this to say
maybe
50.
so
okay
so somehow now c doesn't move as much
when going
downwards but actually maybe i want it
to move
even opposite direction let's just play
around with this a little bit so
i think that this is actually a more
natural movement when characters are
looking downwards because the chin just
disappears somehow
so i'm over complicating this i think
but
yeah let's leave it like this now
and let's try the other one
okay i think this looks good
good this is fine
maybe
four two there looks a little nicer
yeah
okay so a lot of time went to
fine-tuning these things but i think
that we are on to something
and i kind of like this structure that
we are having now and the fact that i
can move the character
in these different
directions
[Music]
no i i don't
think this is great i think
let's try again with the positive
bigger value there
yeah from the side you actually would
like to see
the chin continuing to move downwards
it's really tricky
it's not going to be fantastic and i
think that
i'm going to
limit this
movement a bit more eventually
like maybe not allow the sliders to go
all the way
i really think that you don't need
the most extreme values for the slider
to get a nice looking animation there
and
even values here in between are going to
be
good enough
and we may not even need this crazy
stuff here with the y negative range
there
it's just
way too much
work and too many things to worry about
code will become also difficult
yes
but
or
let's leave it for now and worry about
it a bit later
and i will have also a meeting
in about half an hour so let's see what
is the next step going to be
uh how about i try to draw
the
face
like the eyes for example
maybe that's one challenging thing that
really needs to get done so maybe if i
focus on that one for half an hour i
have enough time i hope
so all of these things that we did now
are probably going to be things that
will
be deleted at some point they are just
reference points
but then at some point
they will be replaced by actual skins
and
make the character look like that
reference drawing
and then we remove that reference
drawing
of course
okay
so
let's
have here the head and
inside of the head i'm going to make a
function
draw
eyes
okay
and
i want these eyes to be
somehow very much influenced by where
a is
right
yes
so let's put here a
as a point that we will be doing this
eyes relative to
and i'm going to do here function
draw eyes
a reference point
and
let me just make the eye that is going
to be
on the right side here
so
i'm going to
begin a path
and move to some location there
draw some curve for the top part
i is very complicated actually
oh boy
oh boy
what did i get myself into
let's just draw the white part of the
eye first
so
yeah
we're gonna start at
this point
but these will be relative to a somehow
so now i want to
click on the points
i mean measure here
coordinates relative to this a location
so
just temporarily i'm going to
modify my function for
printing the coordinates here
so that we have
offset
x is going to be x minus a dot x
and y is going to be y minus a dot y
so
now we get here offset.x and offset.y
and that means that
clicking on a here is going to be pretty
much zero
very good
okay so relative to a
i'm going to
start clicking on some locations now so
this point right here
okay
and then i'm gonna do a
quadratic curve
to
with this control point
and to here
and then another quadratic curve
to here
and another
quadratic curve
here
and another
quadratic curve to here so quite many
points here that i'm listing in the
console
so let me clear this
text
somehow i'm going to align this and
oh
i didn't select all of them
so these are the points
and first i actually want to translate
so
the canvas
before that i want to also save
the context so save
my language changed the keyboard
translate
to the reference x and the reference y
so this is going to be a
and just to remember at the end we also
need to restore
to the last state the canvas and here we
begin a path and we say move to
this location
yes
and then quadratic curve to
i just copied this
using this control point
to
this
location
let me actually cut these that i'm using
already so that my
i don't make mistakes
and then
another control point
to this location
and then another control point
to this location
what did i do wrong
let's undo everything
okay so this was the first i remove it
so then you have control point
to this location
control point
to this location
control point
to this location
and control point to
this location
okay
and uh maybe we want a stroke
or
actually a white fill but
okay
something is there it's not perfect i
think the last click that i did
needs to be
actually perfect to the one in the
beginning
and i don't like this control point
from here
it should be
higher up so
i just moved it a bit okay and a little
bit to the left i think
i want it to be
so
five
okay it's not that bad
and of course this is now
going to move with a but you can see
it's not really
great
the way it's going to move with a
needs to depend also on this slider in a
way
but it's something
it's kind of like how uh
yeah
it's kind of like how glasses would look
like on a person
i think you could easily make glasses in
this way
let's actually try to consider
glasses
maybe i don't know i don't want glasses
on this character i think
but um
so this is just one eye
let's add another function here draw i
like this
and
move the code
from here
to here
and
say now
draw i
so everything should be as before
but
if i'm gonna copy this
now let's say
scale
minus 1 1 so i'm scaling on the
horizontal axis
basically flipping
according to a
to the a point
then i'm getting
here
uh
reverse
okay begin path needs to go here
there was some strange artifact there
and now this kind of looks like the
character
has glasses
um
not eyes because the eye is somehow
getting
away from the
out of the face
i really like what what we are doing
here
i just hope this is possible to follow
along i i think i'm definitely gonna
publish this video it's gonna be long
and some of the things may not be clear
but comment below if you
if you
need some explanation about what i'm
doing
um
yeah
so
let's actually have a function here
called draw
glass
i
draw a glass eye i will comment that is
not used
and uh
now what i want to do is when we are
drawing the eyes actually make these a
little better so that the eye doesn't go
out of the
of the screen like that
so
[Music]
what i want to do is on the positive
value
of this x i want to squish this i
like that somehow
so
when i'm drawing the eyes i don't need
just a reference point
but i need also
the x value there so
how can i get it reasonably well
i could store it inside of a
as the value
let's just do that so
p dot
x
offset is equal to
value
so this is what
is going to happen here
and all of them will start having
x offsets and y offsets
equal to the value so it's just one way
that i can do to
pass
this
0.6 value of my
slider there
from here
to the point
and now this reference point that i have
here
has this x offset as well
so
draw an eye
with the reference x offset and this x
offset is actually going to
translate into the
scale of the eye
let's just do one eye first
and
let's call this value scale this
parameter scale x
and
let's say here ctx
scale
one minus scale x
and this is going to be something like
a value there let's multiply it by
something let's just see what happens
oh
okay this horizontally but vertically i
don't want anything at least not yet so
i just put hundred percent scaling
vertically
and now
okay
not what i want
so the scaling
the scaling that i'm doing here also
needs to be restored afterwards
after we draw that otherwise it affects
the other eye as well and we don't want
that
so i'm gonna do this
and now it affects only that eye
but it's affecting way too much so
i want it to affect less so this is why
i mean here maybe multiply this by
0.3
like that
and now the i
scales well but um
here
in the negative
value it's still scaling
it's stretching it
more than the other eye and we don't
want that i think that i only want this
to happen
for
positive offsets
so let's just put here math
[Music]
math
max the maximum value of 0 and the x
offset
and
let's see what happens
yeah so now the eye doesn't stretch
anymore i think it's kind of like what
happens it does maybe get a little bit
smaller when you do this but
uh
not very much the other one really
becomes uh much smaller because of how
um
how the geometry of the of the face is
it it starts to go behind the eye and
also the nose goes in front of it so
that's something that we will need to
to think about
um so
when the eye shrinks horizontally like
this
it's it's good i think and we can put
here a bigger value i think maybe 0.4
yeah i think this looks great
so the other one
we'll see at the end some fine tunings
if we're gonna change this in some way
but um
okay
so
how about the value here
it's
also needed so for the other eye when
the head turns like this this one should
also squish
so now we have
negative values there
let's just put minus here i think
yeah so that one squishes like that
and the other one squishes like that and
we see if we need to do anything
for those cases when this is a negative
and this is a
positive there
at the end but for now i like the way
that this looks like and
yeah i i think that this is pretty good
so let me try to shape these eyes
a bit more i'm going to draw
actually i'm curious how it looks like
with the glass eye
as well so this one doesn't need the
scaling
i'm just going to put here
draw glass eye on top of one eye and
draw the other glass eye
what happened
why it doesn't work
oh in the beginning everything is
perfect there
now it doesn't look that great
i thought it would look somehow nice
they would need some more adjustments i
think so
but okay a couple of things
let's just remove and leave it as unused
and maybe we adjust them later if we
want glasses but i don't really like the
idea
the stroke here seems to be affected
horizontally somehow
the line thickness here at the bottom
seems to be thicker than
here
i think that if i do the stroke after
the restore
yeah i don't get that effect anymore
which is great
i think it's great
okay
now vertically the eyes
could also do something
i think they should squish
slightly
so let's just put here
uh
ref.y offset
and here as well
and this is going to be scale y
um
okay and here
one means nothing is going to happen
but i want to
if the scale y is something i want to
make it smaller so it's going to be
minus
a fraction of this so scale y times
0.4 and because this is going to be
negative and positive values but i want
only positive here i'm going to take the
absolute value of that
so
nothing seems to happen
let me
take the value from here and log it
i don't think anything is happening
but the values are good
so let me call this
vertical squish
is equal to
this which should work but it doesn't
and um
horizontal
squish
this one works
already
wow something bad happens there
or
oh
this
no now i lost the x behavior
but the white behavior works what the
what is happening
oh
no
something is very weird
it seems to squish the eyes but
not the first time i'm
uh
i'm moving
what is happening
so the x offset
should be good
let's print a here
x offset
it's nothing but then i move y a little
bit
aha
um
i think i know
so these offset values they should be
something in the beginning um
otherwise there is not a number there or
undefined or something and it's causing
some problems so let me put
x offset is zero
and
y offset
is zero in the beginning and we just use
the ones from a at the moment but uh
maybe we need the others at some point i
i don't know
so now
yeah a y works
just
fine as i expect it to
and here yeah this eye gets squished in
the other way
and that one like that
uh
some things i don't like in these
extreme pose but i will probably not let
it go
all the way there so something like this
is just fine
and
some rotation may be needed also to
adjust these but this i'm gonna do later
again it's just something for what looks
good eventually so
seems like i guessed the values quite
well for the vertical movement i really
like how that one
happens
here not sure if this would look better
if everything here would be rotating a
bit but
when we have everything in the drawing
then we will decide these
things now it's just the shape of the
eyes really
so
what i'm gonna do now is um
yeah what i'm gonna do now
it's good i like it
okay so let's make the eye look like the
actual eye in the drawing i still have
about 15 minutes before i need to take a
break
and for that to happen
i'm going to first
instead of doing a stroke here i'm gonna
do a fill
like this so these are now white
but
let me make it
fill style is equal to
rgb a
zero for red
green
maximum green but i'm gonna make it
transparent so that i still see the
shape behind
all right this is
good i think
and i'm going to focus on this right eye
again
so
there is one line here one curve
going around the eye and this actually
i think we already have the points for
that one
so here we started
somewhere there and we had the quadratic
curve like this
the second quadratic curve
might give us
what we want here so i want to draw this
black line
here
so
i'm gonna move to
this point which was the end of the
first quadratic curve
so begin path
this restore i think can go here now
and
stroke
okay
that was fairly easy
i think it's good and it doesn't align
great with the other one i'll see later
if i add some kind of
randomness to somehow make it look more
organic
i just hope i have enough time
and uh maybe this control point could be
a little bit
lower
i don't know i think it's just good
so last i want this
not last but second last i want these
eyebrows
so
let's do the eyebrows next
and
this is not going to be very easy
i'm gonna start
somewhere
here
and then
a control point somewhere here
another control point
i mean end point of the first curve here
and then a control point maybe here
and another endpoint here
another control point
here another endpoint here
and another control point here and
another endpoint here with a little bit
of adjustments we'll see
so
these are going to be the shapes of the
eyebrows and i'm going to use
fills for them
but black a black fill
because i really think that having an
organic
shape for this is important i'm not just
going to draw a very thick line which is
one way you could do this very quickly
so
i'm gonna
i'm gonna
go now
move this restore to the bottom
and begin a new path
yeah i think this restore will have to
need some thinking
otherwise squished lines from previously
might be but let's see but i'm gonna
move to
the first point from here
and then quadratic curve to
here
and then quadratic curve
to
here
and then
quadratic curve
to here
and last but not least
quadratic curve to actually the same
point we start that
my last click here was not that accurate
so now with that
let's stroke this one too
no
fill
and it's actually green
uh let me
change it to black fill style
okay not great yet but
it's something
and i don't really see everything
because of this a point so let me just
hide the point a for now
eyebrows connecting there i don't think
that's great
so the start point could be
more to the right i think maybe
eight
oh no this is this point
i think that one was fine
but uh
actually the last control point this one
yeah this could be
maybe like that
or even less
yeah this is good
i think
let me comment out the eyes a little bit
no too close it will look funny
so
these points are not very good there
my clicking was not very accurate so let
me
put
here how about the value of 0
it's better maybe 0.01
or even 0.2
okay this is quite good and the this
control point here
from
this one
i think this needs to be more
i mean
less minus zero point zero
four
yeah i think this is good
why not
it looks quite okay
some sharp corners around the edges here
but
let's try a bit bigger maybe six
okay
it's not bad i could fine tune these
much more and i could use that bezier
curve
to which has two control points to get
rounded corners
to be more round or there's also the arc
2 method
but
i don't want to over complicate the code
i prefer to use less methods more times
because then it's
more obvious what is happening
and it looks it would look
indistinguishable i think so
okay
it's not bad so this stroke thing is
something that i complained about
that
yeah something will have to be done with
this rotation if i consider these
extreme
sides but i said that i'm probably happy
enough if this
will be like the maximum
movement range
so it's fine it's no problem
okay
uh
i want to get it done and not somehow um
how to say
not have
nothing to show at the end or an
incomplete thing so i prefer to have it
not perfectly polished
but somehow
working
and
this is quite good i think so
let me make these eyes now
or let's draw also the arc for the
circle so for the
i
um
the dark part of the eye whatever it is
the iris and the pupil somehow combined
here so this is going to be just a
single
a simple circle let me put it
here
like this
so
yeah and if this stroke is somehow
bothering that it squishes
here like i said previously we can also
move this here and do the restore before
we do the final stroke there and i think
that this is
going to look exactly the same because
the line and this part here are both
black so
oh
how is this not giving me an error did i
yeah anyway
let's see but uh
an arc so ctx begin path
ctx
arc
at
0.17 and 0.09
with the radius of
i don't know i think i'm just gonna try
to guess it
zero and zero dot
math dot pi times two
and fill here
oh i sure guessed it
very small
very big
wow
what
oh
okay
maybe 0.6
yeah
it's actually not a great idea to use
perfect circles like this i think that
having slight ellipses would be better
again something that i might polish in
the end result
but let me change now this
green transparent fill style to white
and
now the eyes look kind of like the
original eyes but they are
animated
in in a sense that
they are controlled
by this movement
[Music]
the pupils will need to move a little
bit different than now otherwise it
looks too much like these are not eyes
but
stickers that look like eyes
and glued on top of the
of the face
so when looking up it's natural that
these circles move a little bit
upwards
and so on
so i will have to think about
how that could be done
again as a final fine tuning there
but
now this is
good for now and
i'm gonna have to go so i will come back
a bit later today and try to do more of
these graphical things
i think i want to get it done today this
kind of
to get it to look like the original
image and also move somehow
and tomorrow i will try to make it maybe
talk or
something i i don't know yet and it
depends on my speed so far it's been
quite slow but i think that now i have
enough tools with this kind of clicking
to get coordinates and and whatever
these are quite useful things that i
have made
and
the eyes now were quite fast to do
compared to when we started so
i think things will speed up
only speed up from now i hope
depends what i will try to do later so
i'm gonna stop the recording now and
get back
in a while
okay i'm back now for three hours or so
and i think that's all i can do today
i'm getting pretty tired already
so next what i want to do is um
focus on the beard
so i'm going to try to draw the beard
and also
have it go around the face like when the
when the face is moving
like like that
it should wrap around nicely somehow
so the way i'm gonna do it i'm gonna use
the point a from previously
the one here that i uh commented out
previously so the beard is gonna be
drawn
relative to this point as well so
similar as what we do with the eyes
i think that that makes
the most sense
somehow let's see
so
i have draw eyes here
let's have also
draw
beard
according to the a reference point
so we have a function
um
draw beard and let's have this point
called
the reference
there
and i'm gonna copy part of this code
from here for the saving and translating
but this part
is not needed so
now uh i still have activated here
yeah
these are coordinates relative to a
now good
so let me click here
where this beard starts and
actually
i think i'm going to click here for the
starting point
so this is
let me clear the
console here
and say
click here
and a control point should also
be somewhere there
maybe
here and the end point will be this one
now from here this changes curvature
here so let me put
another control point a bit
higher here
and then
the final point here is going to be
right in the middle so
this is actually supposed to be zero but
my clicking wasn't perfect
so let me copy all of these things
right here
and
remove those
things from there
and say
begin path
move to
this point
and then quadratic curve to
using this control point
to this location
and the final one
using this control point
to this location
like so and let's
stroke this for now
um
and refresh
yeah looks pretty nice like what i
expected
but when we rotate here
it's not that bad
there is a problem i think when we
rotate other
place here so
similar kind of trick needs to happen
as what we are doing with the
squishing of this eye we are also going
to have to squish this beard i think
if that makes sense
uh and we said that this is actually
zero
here the last point
now it touches here perfectly
okay
so
how do we do that
squishing
let's do it a bit later so
now this is fine
uh
and i somehow like how this looks
already when turning to one side
this other side that's where the problem
is
maybe we do it now let me see how i did
that before i i forgot
okay we are calculating somehow
a value for the
we are using the offset
as a scalar
only on one side so um
maybe we make
the beard to be something like uh
draw left beard or something
but
anyway
let's see so
scale x
is gonna be
that one
and
i'm just gonna copy this horizontal
scaling for here from here
like so and vertical just hundred
percent for now so i'm not going to
squish it in any way
refresh
something is wrong
i'm squishing it now but i shouldn't
this should happen on the other side
this is happening because uh
now i'm drawing this left side here but
uh
we were working with this eye primarily
and this was just a mirrored part so i
should actually work with the beard on
the right side i i forgot what i'm doing
so i'm just gonna mirror these
coordinates by putting here
plus plus
plus plus
and now the beard is there
and when we rotate like this nothing
happens to it it still looks pretty much
the same
on the other side
it does get
squished a bit
but not enough i think it needs to be
squished even more or
or something needs to happen to this
control point here i think
this control point is somehow too
too much going outside
there
so that the control point there is
the one here
and
let me see if i can make this
like that
it doesn't seem to affect much
okay now it affects way too much
okay i think this looks pretty good
okay
and uh
yeah
let's
check actually also vertically what
happens
so some squishing needs to happen there
as well
definitely
okay and the other way
this is quite good i think already
so the vertical squishing
let's actually start and do it in the
same way as here
for now
and adjust it somehow so the vertical
squishing something to do with this
scale y
so scale y is just the offset we don't
do that
only on one side at least not just yet
so vertical squishing
i mean
scale y is equal to just that offset and
let's put this value here
and now
yeah the beard gets squished somehow but
it's not great
i think
and this is somehow too much so
we don't want it to be like that i think
so
and the other scalar the horizontal i
think needs to be bigger maybe
0.5
so now what happens
okay it's not good the line goes inside
the eye i think point
45 is is nice
yeah that's good and when going
downwards like this
the
slider just goes way too much so i think
that i'm gonna limit these sliders to go
from
minus
0.5
to
minus 0.5 there
and the same for the positive
so that the movement is not so extreme
and that the 3d
characteristics of the face don't
interfere so much
yeah
and
this one
yeah i think that's just fine
not perfect but
somehow i liked
the feeling of it i don't think they
should be linear interpolations but
something else but
i'm quite happy with this at the moment
yeah
and um
so we started up here
now we got
here
and i'm going to actually connect this
right part
of the
face so i'm going to go around it and
connect it back here so let me add
another line to
here
and then
a line two so i'm gonna keep these as
straight lines here they are maybe small
curves but
i just gonna
i'm just gonna have a lot of line twos
here
and the last one is gonna be
a curve to this point
should use the same height for this one
and then connect back to the starting
point so all of these
line two but the last one is going to be
a quadratic
quadratic curve
too
so going back to the beard
and i'm gonna say here ctx line to
this one
and
many other line twos
okay
let's close these like so
and finally
one quadratic curve two
using this control point
to this location the last one but here i
want the same y value as we started
which is the same it's great i clicked
perfectly this time
and i do want another line to the
beginning
or i can also call
close path i think
and it should do the connection probably
let's see
what did what is that
what what is happening
uh i'm missing a point
here
oh no the control point did i click here
before i think i didn't
this was the control point that i need
to do
um
so
this control point was here
and another line to
this one other point that i clicked
earlier i think
and this is just zero here let's
keep it as such
okay now this looks a bit better
okay good
and
how does it look like so
rotating like this
looks quite nice
like that
doesn't look nice so here i want this
point to actually extend
all around the face now
so that the beard covers everything
so i'm gonna do that by
working with this x offset so if the x
offset is negative
then these two points
basically
the control point and this other uh
this point and the control point there
need to be different need to move
further away to keep the shape of the
beard
proper
so
i'm going to define those points as
something so um
do i want to use the linear
interpolation and the range here
probably
so these would be initial starting
points
and then
where did i use this lerp previously
okay
so
we will define a new point we have a b c
let's make d here
so um
d is going to be
this value
here
hmm
now i think i just
call it here constant outermost
point
for the sides so let's have that one be
equal to
an x value
and the y value
and the x here is going to be
this
and the y is going to be this so our
last point here will be
outermost point x and outermost point y
but
when we
if i refresh this it should look the
same
but
now when we
move like this our outermost point is
going to be
depending on
the opposite
of this offset
but um
scaled somehow
and also not affecting here like that so
only when
that thing
moves
let's um
move to the left so only when it's
negative that means that
minus
math minimum of this offset
and zero
let's put zero in the beginning
so i only keep the negative value and i
multiply that by
0.4
a bit too much i think
0.3 maybe
i think i want to keep it
seemingly in the same position so let's
try 0.2
i think i'm happy with that how it looks
like
and the control point
i think control point is not bad let's
see what happens when we move this one
also
okay
okay
so now when moving upwards like this
we want our
bottom point here to actually go
down
quite much so all the bottom part here
should be
should be black now
so
when the
y offset
is
negative
yeah something similar to this minus
minimum of
the y offset
times probably something more here like
three or so
oh i'm moving this point so
it's not good um
okay
outermost point just stays the same and
let's call this right most point
right most point
and
bottom most point
so bottom most point is the one that is
um
this one
and
0 for x
like this
and here we don't need to change that
one so the bottom most point needs to be
before this one
and i just put here bought the most
point x and bought the most point y
so
yeah
now the beard is definitely continuing
more than before it's a big space here
now
um i think i can get this scaler to go
more maybe four
good
but
i think i also want this control point
to be affected somehow
so i will call it
control point
and it will be
this thing right here so
let's
let me copy this
and
say
control point x control point y
like this
and
now for
this one it it also needs
to go low like this but maybe not as
much let's see
so it will depend on on the y as well
yes
i think this shape here is much nicer
now
um it's good
and when turning like this i actually
think
i want to
yeah it should cover the neck here so
for the control point we move it also
like this
so
let's see what happens
yeah now this covers the neck as well
quite nicely
it's
fine
i like it i think it's good
so
now that we have this beard on one side
done i'm gonna do it on the other side
in the same way
let's try also with the other
yeah
something weird happens with the eyes
there when moving really fast but
i don't actually know if they should
squish so much
maybe not even at all
let me remove
make the eyes squish a bit less
vertically so
here when drawing the eyes vertically
vertical squish
let's put this
0.3 there
even 0.2 i think it doesn't need to be
so noticeable
and uh
this might apply also to the beard as
well i think now they're somehow out of
sync
i need to adjust these values a little
bit so this bottom most point
too much going now
and i think the control points
as well
yeah i think it's fine
so let me
now
extract all of these things that we did
here
in the same way that we did for the eye
so
we are passing here
some values for these offsets
for scale x and scale y so let's say
function
draw
beard
draw half
beard
and scale x scale y so very similar to
the other function for draw
i
or half eyes
if that makes any sense
so what we are going to do is
say here draw half beard
with
this for scale x
and
this for scale
y
and we also need some other stuff here
the minimum of zero and fx offset this
is actually the same as our scale x so
here
i can actually
replace with that
and the minimum of zero and y offset
this is something we don't have
so
um
the bottom most
point
scaler
i might call this some something like
an anchor or something i'm not sure
what would be the proper term
but um
let's say beard scaler
or no
it's something there so draw half beard
bottom
the bottom scaler will be the first the
last thing here so
minimum between
0 and y offset
so bottom
scaler
bottom
scaler and i'm just going to put
one
these
the other for better readability
and
yeah let me just copy everything here
like so
put them in the new function
and scale x doesn't need to be defined
here anymore
the squish is still good scale y is
here now
and this bottom scaler is going to be
a third parameter
for stretching the beard down to cover
the neck
let's refresh
and
everything still seems to work
okay
oh something is wrong there
it's completely opposite here so
i messed up something
scale x
um
okay
i'm missing something there i think it
was a minimum
of
i think it was a minimum of
minus this and let's rename these
uh this will be
[Music]
vertical
scalar
and the last one will be horizontal
scalar
so this horizontal scaler is actually
going to be
[Music]
here i shouldn't have renamed
to scale x i think it was a different
value there
i hope
no
or maybe
was it plus
i think some minus plus thing here is
going to fix it
somehow
no i think it was minus but uh
without the minus
yeah okay now now it's good this
stretches out like that
okay great
so
we have draw half beard uh how was the
code doing the eyes it was scaling
something and then
drawing the other eye
with the minus
here
so
let's do the scaling
here
and the other
half of the beard
really horizontally is what everything
matters i think vertically they behave
the same
so maybe putting it in both places is
correct
okay
i don't know what happens there
something strange happens there
maybe the last one doesn't need the
minus somehow i'm tired now and i
don't
no not there
okay
i just hope that i don't need to do the
math and it
it magically works
but something is wrong so
um
am i restoring properly
so draw half beard we have a scale
we don't have a restore so here we have
draw the eye
starting with the save
restore and stroke
so
draw half beard
let's save this
and
i hope this is correct
restore and stroke
okay
this looks good
and vertically
oh yeah
i'm quite happy with this i think some
things could be much better but um
this is nice i really like it
and notice that the lines i drew in the
beginning those are just some kind of
reference and i'm really looking at
these um
new lines that i'm drawing now and at
the animation
so maybe i draw the
beginning lines
gray somehow
so the draw body and the draw head
um
line
stroke
color
is it stroke color no stroke style
i think
gray
yeah but after i do that i make it black
again
so
this is now for this head
lines
here they are gray
um
light gray
too too light gray is just fine so they
are not as striking and the other as the
other ones and i'm gonna do the same
for the body so draw the body
like that and the
black
there
after we
oh what happened no
before
i'm not in the right function am i
it's draw beard
i want drop body
so for the draw body um
so that it's not so
in our face here and we look at the just
the
uh emphasized lines so now when we are
looking at the
dark lines we see the character moving
as he should be moving
now the nose is something
that i want to do next
and it's kind of
silly because in the original
nose like
let me
actually comment out everything for now
so here the nose is somehow like it's
broken to the side when the character is
looking forwards but it looks kind of
okay
i don't think we can do something like
this now the nose
will
look somehow different
needs to look somehow different
and it could be weird when you see the
character from the front but
let's see i'm gonna draw the nose as a
straight line
actually
so i need two points
and this control point
let's see
not the straight line i'm gonna draw it
with the curve so let's say here
uh
something like that
and
i'm going to say
ctx
this should also be yeah it's relative
to a i didn't change that clicking
function yet let's make it draw nose
um sorry
we're still in the head
so in the head
draw nose relative to a
again
so function
draw nose
reference point
and the
ctx
begin path
ctx
move to
0 0.2
ctx
quadratic curve
2
using minus 0.05
0.27
to go to zero point
actually zero i just clicked wrong it
should be the same vertical in the
middle and uh
0.34
yeah and the ctx stroke
like that
i don't know what happened
um
i need the translating also so i forgot
this code right here we need to
translate to the reference point before
we do that and restore when we are done
with with that
okay now this is the
nose here
a little bit different shape than before
and
i don't like it
so
this bottom most point needs to be a bit
higher let's say three
and this control point
more to the side i
clicked on it i should have clicked
outside of it if you remember how bezier
curves work
and it looks kind of too roundish i
don't like it i think it needs to be
also lower
a bit better and maybe just
0 9 here
i think this is ok
maybe i use the bezier
also but
later in the fine tuning if i still have
energy for it
so
it looks okayish maybe not not really
great
in that side and then in the other side
it's it's pretty much horrible so this
is why we need to modify this control
point so this is the tip of the nose
tip of the nose is going to be
having an x and a y
and
the
x
is going to depend on this
x offset
so
let's just say here ref.x offset
and
probably we have to scale it down a lot
but anyway and the y is going to be
same as here
i think
like that so here we just put tip dot x
and tip dot
y
like this and what's wrong here
is equal to a new object like that
so now the nose is a line which is not
really great uh but
at least it's
okay
yeah so this needs to be less
emphasized now
so a fraction of this x offset
i'm going to leave it as a line for now
even though i want to do something about
it later
i want to think about some better better
style for the nose maybe
but
at least
a line is is something that we can deal
with and
it's not bad
i think a bezier curve here would be
better like that one that has two
control points
points
and uh do something about the line
to do
okay
great now
let's do the top part and i'm gonna
i got this idea while i was on the break
previously that i want to have the hair
quite dynamic
like
when the character moves his head the
hair moves
realistically somehow
so
i'm now just gonna make a black
shape around here and i'm gonna draw
these spikes
only
only later
if that makes sense i'm gonna draw them
using some physics
so when the character for example moves
his head like this the hair is going to
be
affected
by
these uh
by those physics there and i notice now
a problem here at the beard these
lines there the last
previous
second to last line two has to have an x
of zero
what happens there
draw a beard
this one
oh no what happened
no after that this one this has to be
zero
yeah and the the the beards don't need
to be stroked
they need the fill
so
and not white phil it looks like santa
claus
i need to put um ctx fill style to black
so i forgot those parts
okay much much better now
nice
and
yeah let's do the
top part
of the head next
top part of the
hair this black part and then do the
physics somehow let's see
so
i really think i'm over complicating
myself but it doesn't look so realistic
and i think it needs more personality
somehow so that physics is gonna make
things much more much nicer i i i hope
let's see
so um
uh
half
hair is going to be the the thing that
is going to be drawn here somehow
to do the top shape of the head
of the
some black lines here basically
uh
yeah and it should continue with the
beard
at least on this side and then
maybe i'm gonna
make these
crazy things there these shapes as well
i wonder if it's a good idea or not
i think it's a
not the great idea
let's just pretend i have a very
small
haircut like very short hair
just coloring the head for now and think
what to do with those later
so draw beard
draw
hair
also with a as the reference point i
think
yeah we didn't really need b and c
we would need them if we want to rotate
the head like this but i don't want to
do that it's just too much work
too much trouble now so this is just
really fine by me
i kind of like we forgot about the nose
when it's connected to
scaling the nose vertically we forgot
that but i kind of like it that it
connects to the beard only when pointing
down or when pointing up like this it
somehow gives more
personality i i think it's a mistake
that i want to keep
some okay let's do the head part
what oh draw hair not defined yes
so
i'm going to copy draw beard
pretty much like this
and
call it draw hair
and it's going to be draw half here
and draw half here
and now i'm going to copy draw half
beard
and make it like that but change the
coordinates somehow
so
let's see if we can do both at once even
though i have a bad feeling about this
so draw half beard
uh
now becomes
draw half hair
and
move to
so this point
yeah
air conditioner makes some strange noise
here so
this case
is uh
so draw half here
uh this point is
this point here so i definitely want to
keep it
the next one
i would like to draw a line
to somewhere here but with a very big
curve like that so
let's
have here a control point maybe
here
and
here the center point
so
quadratic curve to
and
i should draw the right side always so
the right side is the base and the other
one is reflected so
this is plus
0.47 47
and
minus 0.
44.
and here we have a 0
and a
minus zero point
44 really i clicked on the same y
okay so this is now
going like that
and i want to go also upwards up to this
point right here which is
point b
so
the next
it's actually going to be a line
to a vertical line
to
b i think so b dot x and b dot
y
no need for this part
and then uh going back down from b to
this outer connecting part at least
so um
a quadratic curve to
and
a control point maybe here
and
that point i'm going to have to copy
from somewhere but let's just click
click it for now so this is going to be
the control point and the last one
is going to be
the right most point so it's complicated
with some scalar and things like that so
let's just do this
and
put here right most point x
and uh
right most point
y
no need for
maybe no need for control points
we see later
we might have to adjust this when the
rotations happen
and the close path so that
the small line here gets drawn also
and let's have this
let's have it the field
as before
and refresh the page
oh my
oh
oh boy
the b is not good anymore because i'm
remember i'm giving here relative to a
so i need the new new point i'm just
going to put the dot here
minus 0.57
so
0 and
minus 0.57 so that's why the pointy head
is there like that
i think it can be even higher up so
minus 0.6
65
okay let's disable a b and c so that i
see
something there i don't think we're
gonna need b and c
for
much let's say
maybe later
but i'm gonna disable
code printing them there now so that i
see what is happening here a little bit
of a pointy tip here but i don't mind
the inside part is great the outside
part is not good
and
and something weird happens here so
not much weird happens there but
i do need this control point to be
further away
so
something like that and i have a feeling
this one needs to be somehow
um
this control point and it may need to be
tailored in the same way for this right
most point
yeah maybe a bit too much let's say
60.
i think that's good and let's make it
higher up like also 0.6 both of these i
think
it's um
this is fine
mm-hmm
okay
and the y value
yeah
i'm quite happy with this
i think
i somehow don't like that it's getting
so squished there but um
like here it's squishing the forehead
um yeah
anyway it's
it's fine
hmm
i think we will need to use b and c
eventually
maybe we see
okay
uh
but something is really wrong like this
like if if somebody is moving their head
down like that
you expect
this part to stay up to somehow
a lot of black hair needs to be needs to
be there
so
moving head down like this
should have that effect that
that part doesn't
go down
so
when we draw this we have the rightmost
point
for this connection
and we also have
this is the starting then we have the
curve here
let's say this is good
and then the line two here this point
this is something that is not great at
the moment
so this needs to be
somehow with this vertical
squish maybe
no
so there is some squishing here
happening let's disable it because i
forgot exactly what it's doing
okay this actually looks much
much better now
but we do
need something
yeah this looks much much better now
but we do need something for
keeping this point up there
and probably also controlling this
control point of it
so i think
we need something similar to
yeah
let's just go and look at the beard
again
and the bottom most point we will need
something like a topmost point
so
top most point
and this is going to be this value here
so
maybe that
and
let's move this
like so
this one here where it's needed
and um
topmost point x
and topmost point
y like this
so
now
this is good i like it
apart from these control points that
need to be done but it also needs to
continue to happen so
this vertical scaler
from there
i think should happen all the time
so we have here
this one and i'm using a minimum value
there what happens if i just put the
offset
i'm doing it just on the right side but
yeah
this is better now
so a different way for calculating this
vertical scaler here
and i'm going to do the same thing also
on the left side
and
i'm going to need to
do that also with the control points
so
the control point
let's see how i did it for the beard
previously
so
i think
i just figure it out somehow
here so draw
uh
this was the control point so
control point
0.6
0.6
minus
vertically it's what needs to happen so
minus this same thing i think might be
good
not really
oh i'm not using it
control point
x
and then control point
y
e
what happened
oh it was minus
yeah okay
okay i kind of like this
way that these things are looking i like
that the forehead now stays larger
and
head seems to be moving fine
yeah there should definitely be some
kind of rotation happening
but
it's way too much i don't think i will
have time for that
and this one
yeah okay it's it's fine
okay
somehow the shape of the head is not
great
i think the
horizontal scaler is also something that
needs to be used here maybe
in the control point
maybe in the other way minus horizontal
scaler
i'm a bit tired now and i just can't
concentrate on the math i'm just playing
around with the numbers i know that one
of them is supposed to work
um
but
let's try 0.3 for the head
i'm just playing with the values so that
this
looks more
no not there
so that it looks good to me
yeah okay
i think we are fine for now
okay
let's draw something easy like the body
next
so i do have the neck
here and the kind of shape for for this
body
but um
and actually
let's also add colors so that's let's
add the color for the skin
i'm gonna
i'm gonna get the color from here using
some color picker tool
i will
do a print screen and i open paint you
won't be able to see this but
i get the color picker in paint and then
i look at the color values
so
they are
exactly
red
green
and
blue
like so
so what i'm gonna do
with that is where we are drawing the
head here i'm going to put um
a fill here
and the fill style
let's say skin tone
and i'm gonna define this skin tone
somewhere at the top for now
rgb
with these things
and the refreshing now
doesn't do anything
weird
so i'm drawing the head
why isn't it coloring
oh
these are the
mid lines um i think the these ones are
the outside yes something like that
but now these points on the sides
are way too too much i want these to be
inside of the hair region
yeah so
minus
0.4 i think
too much
0.45
okay this is good
maybe
yeah starts to look like some real
real character there now with the skin
colored in
okay something here is not quite right
and
also here something is not quite right
yeah let's
starts to be tiring already
here it's not perfectly filling this
shape
let's just leave this for
for a moment and worry about that a bit
later
i would like to use somehow the previous
coordinates that we are calculating
there but i have a feeling it's not so
easy
because of the symmetries and what we
are trying to do
we leave it for now
uh let's just get other stuff that is
more easy to do because my head doesn't
work very much now
so
i'm gonna do this
neck and the body there
so when we are moving the head to the
right like this
i would also like to
maybe move also
part of the
neck a little bit
some kind of movement
should happen otherwise it just looks
like you're some
rotating head on the
on a screw there on some
metal
structure
also when we are drawing the body
i want to
feel it some ctx
fill and
ctx fill style equals to skin tone
yeah that's good
okay but the lines here are not very
thick i think
what happens there
should the stroke be after the fill or
yeah i guess that was it
okay
now
yeah what i was saying that
for example
one of the points here i think it's
probably the first one
and the last one where we are
going here
so these points i would like to somehow
connect to
a the a offset in some way
so
plus
a dot offset
x offset
i think that's enough but
[Music]
scaled somehow
i don't know what happened
let's remove it from here have it just
in one place
very strange
oh
okay these values are just so small
uh
something like this maybe
yeah now the neck somehow
rotates in that way moves in that way
somehow and i i like that movement and
i'm gonna do a similar thing for this
other one so
like that
it somehow looks a bit better
yeah
okay good
also this one would be nice i think
so
we have
the y offset effecting there
and
i think i'm gonna do the same
here as well
i don't know if this is going to be a
great tutorial i don't think it is a
great tutorial but um
many of these things would need to have
proper names
for the variables
but it will end up into something
that
i'm gonna find a use for
okay it
doesn't seem to
to behave
and then i don't think i'm gonna work
with this code very much anymore after
it's done and
something useful
but uh let's see so
at least somehow the
ideas of having different keyframes and
interpolating between the frames somehow
should
be should be
clear to some extent
okay what is happening there i want to
disable the head
just to focus on the body
it's doing something but not
not very
visible it's just behind
everything there
so
yeah
okay
let's put
what
a smaller value there
um
doesn't seem to
affect very much
and i think this is flipped yeah this
should be
minus
that offset
yeah let's see so now if i go back here
and
reactivate this
no
no no
uh
so this
at the
negative side should be up
oh no it wasn't flipped damn i
i don't like this i'm getting tired
i had a long day already
uh
maybe this is fine
i think the control point is the issue
we don't really see the change bit
because the control point stays the same
and then the changes when this head is
moving so
it's not that
yeah it's not that significant it is
moving a little bit
but not not very much
and this is a bit too much i think so
when we draw the body
maybe half of this is
enough
yeah it doesn't need to be exaggerated
mm-hmm
okay
now the clothes so
let me
comment out this body part
for now
and
draw these clothes somehow
so i'm gonna do this
trying to copy these shapes here
so
yeah
i don't need to
uh
this get chords uh i don't want this to
be an offset relative to
a anymore i want the original code
so that
i just get the coordinates inside the
screen where i'm clicking
like this
so now
i'm gonna click here and i'm gonna say
add the control point somewhere outside
here
and then
another point here
another control point here
another point here
control point here
a point here
control point here
and point here so that's going to be
that side on the left
and
now in the body
okay
so
doing now um
begin path
and then move to
move to
this one
in the beginning
and then this quadratic curve 2
where we use this as a control point
and go here
and then use this as a control point
to go
here
and another one
where we use this is the control point
to go
here
and the last one where we use
this as the control point
to go here
okay ctx
stroke
yeah this is fine maybe here
i don't like this control point very
much
i mean this end point
now this control point here this needs
to be more to the right
i think
negative value so it grows like that
okay
okay maybe that's not the problem the
next control point here maybe should be
a bit more upwards
yeah i like this shape now much better
here
okay
so that's
one side there
and we can fill it with that kind of
green color i'm just going back into
paint to
get the color code of that color
154
153
and one
blue is one
okay
so
shirt color
like this
um
so back in draw body we have here
ctx
fill style
is shirt color and we also give this ctx
fill
like this
what did i press on my computer
okay
not okay
i pressed something
okay uh this fn key somehow
right
so this is one part here done
i'm just going to comment it out a bit
and
do the same thing on the other side i
want these to be somehow
separate
lines so it looks more organic i'm gonna
do
a click here
this is where i'm gonna begin
so
and a curve that goes
like this okay
undo
start here a control point here
going here
then a control point here
going here
control point here
going here
control point here
going here
and the control point here
going here or so
so let's copy that
and um
keep these coordinates there
and
let's do
a begin path with the move to
starting point
and then
control point here
going there
control point
and point
control point
end point
control point
and point
and control point end point
okay this is good
but now it's using the
skin tone
which is the last fill style so now we
have
these things here
they look really good i think
but um
so here we started like that ended like
this
i think this end should be lower so that
it covers this
stroke there
yeah let's
try
eight
oh no it grows the other way around so
point line
yeah
doesn't seem to work
i think this is
okayish
not okay
let's leave it with nine zero and
do another bit of a curve there as well
so
this control point
i'm going to put it here and take us
back to the starting point
like this
but i don't want that stroke to be there
i think so let's see if i do this
i think this is just perfect
okay
let's put also the body back on
for reference
okay
and now i'm gonna
draw the shoulders and that part
pretty much
copying
going over this skin part right there
so
yeah
hmm
and i'm gonna also
add a few
scalings
i mean a few
translations based on these sliders for
the whole body i think that will amplify
the
the feeling of movement make it look
even better let's see
but before that let me
uh
so this is now the
this point right here
is this one
i'm gonna need the new one somewhere
maybe here let's just draw this
i'm gonna make new points there i'm
gonna start with the point here
actually this one will be zero
and then it will go
here
and then
line to
here
and
control point here
line to somewhere there and then
i mean curve 2 somewhere there but this
will be outside the screen
so
before we do these with the shirt collar
we are going to do something else with
the shirt caller
so
i'm gonna
this was a zero actually and this was
1.1
or something
and
we do a move to
this center location
and um
now we do
a line
to
this place
and
then align to this place
and the last one is going to be this
quadratic curve
too
with this control point
and
the last point there
so this should be fine
but now we need a line to
[Music]
the other side so basically this one
with the plus
and
a quadratic curve to
this will be same with the plus and
going to this coordinate actually
also with the plus on the other side
and then
this one
with the plus
and back to here or just doing
close path
and we need a
fill and a stroke as well
so this is fine i think
i'm missing a begin path
okay
and here i'm just going to
tuck these
points a little bit
i can see a little bit these corners
there
i think this was fine and such but this
one was like that
okay
so
better
[Music]
this is not great i see a small line
there from
this last connection
uh with the closed path so this needs to
be a bit
lower i think let's try
86.
let's try 87.
can we go 88
okay
good
good good
but this looks a little bit weird so
head moving neck is moving a little bit
it's okay
but the rest of the body just completely
still
so i'm gonna
do something about that as well
um based on that a point
so when i'm drawing everything here like
the body and the head i'm actually going
to do a ctx
translate
first to save
ctx translate
a dot offset
x
or was it x offset
and
multiplied by
0.04 or something small
and
y offset
also multiplied by that um
i don't think i need the y offset let's
just put it zero
it would look a bit strange
so i restored this now
so everything moves now a little bit
while the person is moving i don't
really like it
it's not fantastic
maybe this value should be very low
like that
it's not not very great
let's uh
restore this somehow after the body
this looks a bit better
and
let's actually
scale
also
so that it goes
um
one minus a dot x offset multiplied by
zero point
zero five
and one
so
not good
it's good in this direction but not good
in this direction
absolute value might fix it
yeah this is okay
and maybe even a smaller value here like
like that
it gives some kind of movement it of
course this should be
skewed and it should give you a 3d
perspective and
all these points should be actually
somehow
computed with a 3d perspective in mind
but
i don't know how to use
the webgl canvas for example and i said
i don't use the internet
and also
i think it's too much trouble and when
you try to do things in a 3d environment
that are
supposed to be 2d
they don't look the way i i like them to
look
if that makes sense
so this is just fine i think for for
what i'm doing here
and um
hmm
yeah good okay what happens when we move
vertically
okay let's see if now i have to
energy to feel this
shape
when drawing the head something is
off there
yeah so i'm drawing the head
[Music]
i really feel like i want to disable all
of these for a while and see what
happens with this shape
okay yeah we were using those
b and c points
let's add the
a b and c points back in
that was a kind of a good idea but
somehow i ended up using just a as the
point
it would have been a better 3d
perspective there
let's put here
ctx global alpha
0.4 and
reset it to 1 at the end
so what i'm gonna do is i want to see
through the head
the other shape and see what is the
where is the problem coming
from
so here for example
i think the bottom of the beard
should go more down
and then maybe
we do something right here
as well
so
let's go to the beard
draw half beard
so the bottom most point
let's try this one
with the three and also vertically here
with the 0.3
i think that's fine
now this right most point
so this is something that i want here to
have a bit bigger maybe
47
like that
not really
it was fine before
so not the right most point but the one
so this control point is
i think the outside one
this quadratic curve to
what were these two things
so these
and that that means this point right
here
this one
end point here
no that that this is the start point i
forgot it starts right here so
it should be
39 or something so i want to move it a
bit closer to the eye here
like that
and now if i do this
and that
almost good
so also this control point right here i
think also
a lower value maybe
33 there
yeah now this looks good
[Music]
and here
this outside part
so
the
control point here
the x should be
bigger maybe thirty
eight or something
yeah and the right most point
maybe
46.
i think this is good
and the the hair needs to still connect
so we have changed now this point here
and also the right most point i'm
copying them just for
reference and i'm gonna draw go now to
draw half
hit
no hair
draw half hair
and this one was also starting at
it needs to start here
and
the right most point
now this is a 46
here
so let's see now
uh
global alpha i want to
remove this trick for making things
transparent just so i see through
them and
okay
almost there
yeah this is fine
it's kind of funny
okay
okay
a little bit
inwards so um
the one control point from draw
half
beard
uh
the first one from here
should be inwards a bit more so
maybe like that
maybe even more
okay
i think this is just good
so
we have done
quite many things
still many things to do
but i need a brick
so
i'm gonna take few minutes break and
then i come back for another
hour or so
and then tomorrow
more interesting stuff
i'm gonna think about this also when i
walk to work
and
usually that's when i do most of the
great idea
thinking
moments
yeah
okay so the years are still missing
actually
and i really want to do the hair
um
so that it's
dynamic so when the character moves like
moving his his head like this i want the
hair to be shaking there i think it
would look very nice
and
and i want the character to talk so this
is something that i really want to do
tomorrow and i'm not entirely sure how i
want to do that
i have some videos about this
talking pumpkin that i did at some point
where i used the microphone
to
get a different
to get the volume and depending on the
volume open the mouth more or less
i could do that but i think it wouldn't
be very
organic
people open their mouths in so many
different ways and the
volume is just one number
so
i i'm thinking about using webcam and my
face and doing some kind of detection on
the face
i really want to do these two features
otherwise i think i'm gonna lose this
competition because i've spent so much
time and i just have a
nodding character and
he seems to agree with me
okay
but um
i will take a break and uh in a few
minutes i continue and try to draw the
ears
and maybe i begin with the hair in some
way
something
i might i think i should also clean up
the code before i end today so that i
have it easier tomorrow it's a bit
it's not great
i i should use some
objects maybe or
at least separate the code into files so
that it's easier to
to find the things this already starts
to have quite many
lines of code
yeah
okay be back in five minutes
okay i'm back
so i think one of the things i want to
do is the years
now
and um i'm going to go back
to the click event listener here and
re-get
um
coordinates with respect to
a
so the same way we did for the eyes
i'm going to refresh this
and
yeah so where are the years now they
don't align very well here
i'm going to try to
map the locations where they should be
somewhere here
so i'm going to say
i'm going to click where i think the
location should be
so one is here
with um
control point
here
and
another point here
and then
control point here
here
another control point here
here
another control point here
here
i might need to
adjust these a little bit
yeah i think it's too complicated shape
let's let's make a simpler one
so starting here
control point here
and here
and
another control point here
here
let's see how this looks like
so
we have the draw ahead and
draw
years with respect to a
so function
draw
years
oh and i did everything on the left side
again
let me do it
one more time and on the right
okay
i think this ended up even better
so
let's do that
and um
now we have
a save and a translate
and it ending with this restore
and
reference point passed here like that
and what we do now is
move to
this first location
and all of them are quadratic curves
so i'm going to say
quadratic curve to
this
with this
and
this
to this
and finally
this
to this
and ctx
fill style
equals to skin tone
ctx fill
ctx stroke
um
it's something
maybe i want this first control point to
be more to the right
no i i don't maybe i want this end point
yeah maybe something like that and then
the this control point maybe
that looks good
i think
and
close
path as well
now there is a line here that is thicker
i think the starting point can be a
little bit to the right
so like that
maybe also a little bit lower
more low
yeah why not
and um
i think now this can be
left a little bit
i think this looks okay
uh the last
thing here i think could be
lower maybe
not that one
mm-hmm
okay
something like that this is just fine
so i'm actually gonna
copy
this draw
make it into a
yeah some
smart things need to happen here because
this here on the right
should actually disappear
at some point
yeah this is not very easy
it's the first thing that we need to
make disappear
to make it vanish when the character
rotates like that
so if we go to the draw
eyes for example
let's take this as a reference
draw
years
and
draw a year
like this
i think it's pretty much the same as
what the eyes are doing maybe a little
bit different
so i'm gonna
make a new function here
draw
here
uh
x
scale
or
scale x
like this and the draw
i
is having here these two things
i think we will need
something similar as well
and
ctx restore because we are scaling them
okay two years there
uh this one is quite
yeah it is scaling itself now it's
better
but
it should also
it should also scale
uh
i think
not just in this case
not not just with the maximum
i think we just put here
x offset let's see
yeah it really needs to be
more here somehow and i would like it to
squish more
yeah this is good
but um
these locations also need to be
translated somehow let's do ctx
translate
scalex
no
nothing vertically just horizontally
and
it's way too much so let's do it
by a small factor
yeah i think this is fine
now i'm worried what happens here
it's not horrible
some squishiness is happening which i
don't
necessarily like but i think it adds to
some personality to the character so
it's fine
okay
and uh drawing the head
i think it's just too high up
so when it's normal like this i would
like it to be a bit lower
it's just too
too high up i i think
so or maybe the body needs to be
higher
let me do a quick translation for the
body
to be higher
and i think that will fix the problem so
here
okay maybe a bit too much point
six
okay
yeah a little funny shape here but i
really think that when i'm gonna do the
um
here with the physics hopefully i'm
gonna do the hair with the physics then
it's gonna be good and
the year here
i don't know if it really needs to be
covered
i would definitely cover it but it's not
so easy to do that
i think also
we might do some tricks with the with
the hair later
to cover it
but uh
don't have a clear vision there yet my
hair now is also a little bit different
than in that
initial drawing that we are
getting inspiration from
and it's shaking also to the sides so it
goes also here
i might need to redesign also the
character a little bit
maybe these top parts don't need so much
attention
well let's see
yeah i think i'm gonna actually i don't
even see my ears anymore
because there is hair is covering them
so
i think that i don't need to worry much
about the ears there
even if you will see a little bit here
because the hair will be covering it
it won't
be a big deal i think we're fine
but now uh i think we are done with this
kind of
basic
character
movement
and
i'm not gonna polish this much more
maybe something with the nose if i get
some better idea
uh to make it look nicer when it's
straight
watching straight at us like this
uh
but i'm quite happy with what we have at
the moment
here these
lines look too thin i think that we need
to
stroke
the
that part
okay
this gray here is not
needed anymore
uh huh
so let's put here
skin part of the body
and this is gonna be
um
shirt
part of the body
and now here we have those that color
or the neck
neck
region
and the shirt
second
part like that
and
so this draw body
hmm
um yeah the problem is stroke should be
after the fill
there
this one is fixed but this one
i don't want that connection there
so
i think i'm gonna do
fill and stroke
now this last fill is not good
it
destroys part of the stroke
so
this part here is something i don't like
now
i think i just do
begin path
yeah begin path
that and fill
i need the move to before so
move to there
okay almost i think this control point
needs to be
lower so
like that
no
oh
this is so horrible
yeah this shape now is just this part
right here
i should use a move to a bit higher up
so
let's leave this as such
and this move 2 goes to
89 here
that looks good
okay
finally great uh i will also remove now
a b and c again from there
and um
let's move the draw body function
in
a new file let's call it body dot js
it's not a class but
i don't know
it will be very useful to keep
everything inside the class eventually
but now i just want to separate the
functions
so
that one goes in the body
and now
let's put in the head
draw head
and all these other things draw ears
draw ear draw nose draw hair
half hair
beard half beard eyes high
this one we don't need anymore i'm not
gonna worry about this glass i
think so let's put this
head js
okay
and let's clean up a bit what we have
here
so
um
high speared hair nose ears
it's fine
and
i'm just gonna group these
a bit like that
i think they're a bit clearer and i like
to separate save and restore so that
i notice them easily whenever
these
modifications to the context are are
done
yeah the to-do for the nose is still
here
draw hair
yeah
to me the code is clear
but there are many many of these
values that are used to define the shape
and it's actually not easy and
not really needed to come up with names
for these things
i think it would be possible to export
all these values in some kind of json
format or something
and then load them in
but
i'm not going to spend time on on that
this feel can happen before the restore
here i think what was this
half beard
only the
stroke is affected in in width when you
do that
so we have eyes also
so here we have the eyes
the main the white part
and then
the
eye brows
just one
and uh what is this thing oh yeah the
let's call it
pupil
i'm not sure how you write it but
it's gonna be like that now i don't have
internet
and what is this
oh yeah that one line
this one line here
half
contour line
something like
that and
let's separate that as well so i is more
complicated it needs special comments
there
the beard
doesn't really need special comments
because it has some variable names that
are
self-explanatory
and of course you may need to play
around with these a little bit to
change but i did all the drawing that i
want to do and i'm happy with it i don't
want to update this anymore
so that is the definition of this
character pretty much
and
same goes for the hair i think it's well
commented here
this scale y is actually not used for
the hair apparently
so let's remove this
so the vertical squish thing is not used
anywhere this is just the one here
good
simpler
code this simpler now
okay draw body is not defined
we need to go to index.html
and
include these scripts
before we write this script right here
so let's say
script
source is equal to body js
i think like that
and
hit
js
okay things seem to work again
this is so funny it looks kind of
unnatural
it's a very unnatural
i stopped liking it now
i really think that the hair is going to
change a lot of
things here
i hope
i hope it can give a 3d
look to it and also the fact that it's
going to move it's going to make things
better yeah some polishing will be
needed
we are not done
i still have maybe
20 30 minutes
maybe even a bit more
and um
i wanted to do something completely
different but let me clean up this a
little bit
so
a little bit more
still quite much cold here what do we
have this lerp
i usually have a utils file
let's call it math this time
i'm gonna put there the linear
interpolation for example
and these update points something quite
general
draw
point i think i rename it back to
utils
and put also these
this draw point there so it's not just
math but now also some visualizing thing
that we use in different places
and this is just the helper thing this
function will be
removed
like that
like so
now live points so these are
those things that we have been using but
this bees
i guess it's
used somewhere
at least to define that head
the colored part the skin colored part
of the head
okay we'll see tomorrow
okay so now this utils let's include
utils as well i'm gonna put it first
here
utils js
we keep these points
then the animation so
this click and the get coordinates
actually also the
this event listener
will need to be removed afterwards
so
[Music]
i mean doesn't need to be removed but it
won't
do anything it's just printing stuff in
the console
so
yeah
animate function will stay and it has
draw me
and this part will also be removed
it's just that background
character i think we can actually remove
it even now
but
let's just keep it a bit longer for
reference here
okay
and the draw me function
does a little bit of scaling so that the
character
appears a little bit more
to move
sideways
not really 3d but at least
if you're not paying close attention it
feels like that
and this is not fantastic really but
not horrible i think the hair will make
a very big difference and the beer beard
might be adjusted a little bit after
that let's
let's see
maybe the head could be
the body could actually be a little bit
higher up
also
yeah
okay
this one is
the slider so this is called when
hmm
yeah i had some more some other ideas
originally to make it look even a bit
more 3d with these
other things there
but
and the abc points
they were
supposed to
do something a little bit more somehow
shape the head
but
it's not horrible okay i still want to
do a few more things
so let me
remove these points again they are
disturbing a bit now
and i'm actually gonna
hide that
character on the background this circle
here and
i might need that code again to compare
in the end but for now this is what we
are having
and uh oh looks like some space here at
the bottom let me just make
the body
be
a little bit longer
at the bottom
here so
outside the screen those two points
i think it was a bit
far enough anyway
but this is some
side of the canvas that just looks like
that
okay so what i still want to do now is
um
add a completely new thing i want to add
our my camera my webcam
and
somehow do basic image processing there
and see if i can move this head with
the camera instead
i think it's a bit too much now it's
late but at least i want to start
something
so
let me see
i want to do this
here
let's just make a new file called this
camera js
and include it here
camera js and here i'm gonna write
navigator
media device is
get
user media
and i'm going to get
the video but i think that i'm going to
also use the audio later
i think in the end i will want to
support uploading a video and then it
just the character is going to move
according to that video somehow let's
see
so
but for now just the video here i think
is just fine so we get the user media
and this returns a promise so
we do then
uh we use the data so we have the
data coming
from the promise when the promise
succeeds
and uh
i'm gonna define
a video
object um
i don't add it to the
dom but
element a video
element
and
then i'm going to set this to the data
that comes from the device so
source
i think it's source
object
is the data
and we are going to play this video so
if i'm going to change this from the
camera to the
to some video
this is where i want sound to also
display later
i will remember i don't need to do that
so then when this is loaded it's like
on loaded
data
we get a new function new callback
function
and
here
i
can start to
do something
with this video like start the
processing and so on
so
we might also have an error
if
when you do this
it's going to ask you on the screen if
you allow or not
to
to give the camera so this might give an
error and we can catch that error like
that
uh
i just make an alert here and say
no
camera
failed
something like that
okay
why is this highlighted like that so we
have this
i'm not using the error anywhere
was it so that in javascript catch is
not like this but it's a callback
function
okay
and now i have to close this one
i need to close this
catch somewhere
this is a function i have the alert
closing the function and then i have to
close this catch
you
i just don't know what the problem is
let's um
run this
and
look in the console
what is that
oh
this then
no no no no
no this is then
this then has to be closed
before
before the catch
it's then and then it's a catch yes
okay it
allows the camera and then
could not start video
source i think this is the error message
from here
it could be that i'm using the webcam
here and
that webcam
doesn't let me use
yeah
uh
let's see if i can make the web
the browser
have a different webcam
i have a webcam in my
laptop
here as well in the front
okay
so
i did something
maybe
refresh
okay
something worked i think it's using my
front camera
let's try to display this
camera on some other kind of canvas
i'm going to put another small canvas
under these sliders there so i'm going
to say
canvas
id
cam canvas
and i'm going to
get the reference to this one as well
somewhere here in the camera code
and i will say
camera canvas
um
i think i make this one as big as the
video is going to be it's going to
simplify things a bit and let's put here
it
i can scale it with css later
and
let's try drawing the image so
i need
i need a context for this one as well
okay
and i'm gonna draw the image
of the video
at zero zero
so
i don't need the width and height
because the canvas has the same height
as the
video
so let's remove this log
and
try
to refresh
okay
but this is very large now
so
with css i'm going to say
um
max with
okay
i think this is just fine for debugging
and fits in my screen
quite
nicely
i think
so
this is the other camera from the front
and that's just one snapshot because we
are not animating these
cameras in any way so i'm going to copy
this style from here
and i'm going to add it for
cam
canvas
like this
so when i refresh now
okay
now the room here is not fantastic with
the lighting and everything
i might change the room tomorrow
i think i'm going to use a better
room
and um
let's try to begin to do something with
the camera here so i just hope i
i
at least get it to animate
so
here i'm going to call
wait i already have an animate function
here
okay
so what i need to do here is
take this video out
with let
like this
and
i'm going to
go back here and say
okay this cam canvas also needs to be
up here
and
camera
context
okay so camera context
camera context draw image to video
and then draw me on the other canvas
so now the video should animate
if i
save this and refresh
what is happening
okay it works it was
it did an error here because the video
was null
and it never got to request animation
frames so animation didn't start and
yeah
even after i pressed that allow button
for the webcam okay
now
if we have the video then do that
and
i really want to get somehow the
locations
of the
of some pixels there so i always use
these kind of markers i don't have a
blue marker here
tomorrow i need something blue
and
yeah
spider-man is blue
let's try with spider-man
so
let's write the function
for
a utility function for
get
marked locations so we're gonna look for
the color blue
so a color of zero red
zero green
maximum blue and we're gonna use a
threshold
like this
and i'm going to get the
data
from the context i need here
um
the image data as well
so
here
i'm drawing it on the context so then i
want the image data
camera context
get image
data
from zero zero to
cam
canvas
width
cam canvas
height
like this
and then
this image data has a data attribute
i just pass it completely to that utils
function so
the marked locations are going to come
from get marked locations
using the image data
and the color and the threshold but i'm
gonna keep those values
inside of here
i might put the color picker or
something let's
let's see later what happens
but
yeah get marked locations from the image
data and let's console
log
logs length like this so the number of
items in this array
so now in the utils
i need image data here also
and
let's just
console log image data
data
length
see how big this array is
i remember
this kind of thing quite well
an error
okay this is not returning anything
yeah so here we have
0 is
this empty array and this is the size of
image data
so
these are values
are this image data data
is having
i mean this data now is having this many
numbers and it's the width times the
height
times 4 because each value for each
pixel is the red green blue and alpha
components
so i'm going to loop
through every four
groups of four and i'm gonna say
red is going to be data of i
green is data of i plus one
blue is data of i plus two and alpha
would be data of i plus 3 but we don't
need that so now i have a rgb value
for this pixel
now if this rgb value is
a match
our gb is a match to our
caller that we are given this blue color
there
so
match
between these
colors and
under the threshold
let's say the threshold is going to be
something like
50.
then this is gonna
add something to this locations array so
i'm gonna say here
an empty array to begin with
and uh
the locations is gonna push
an x
um
an x and a y
so the x and the y we need to calculate
them x is going to be
i think the floor
of
the index of the pixel
so the index of the pixel is i divided
by four
because we're going in groups of four
and then the x is going to be
p
index
divided by
image data
width
and y is going to be
the modulo i teach this all the time in
my videos like all the marker effects
have this this thing there i'm just
trying to do it mentally and i hope that
i don't mess up
index modulo
data
with
and these values are going to go now to
our locations array
and which we return here
so we need two more things we need this
match function
match color one color two
and this is just going to end the
threshold
and this is just going to say
if the distance between color 1 and 2 in
the 3d space
is less than the threshold then it's a
match so
return
distance c1 c2
less or equal to this threshold
and here we say function
distance
and this is going to be
distance between two points p1 and p2 in
3d space
um
euclidean distance
like that
no
like that
okay and now return
square root
of this distance
so
this should be the distance
in 3d space
any space really because we have here a
for loop
like that
so now what we are going to do
is
test
i think
i don't know i'm getting tired
let's refresh
so it's a zero there but if i bring this
cup here
it's still zero
i think that these uh
blues
i need to go
soon
maybe five more minutes i tried to
detect some blue color here
um
i think the
value
of the threshold could be bigger
i think something doesn't work so
let me put a
break point here
and go inside of this
function
okay
things look good so i don't know why it
doesn't work
a bigger threshold is not a great idea
because we are approaching too much
the values of
other colors
oh okay
well something blue there but i'm gonna
go tomorrow in another room oh i have a
pen here
okay
so something works i think
these colors are detected
let's see
10 more minutes i want to do something
with all these let's average the
locations
so
these are going to be x y locations
the values from here
so i'm going to say
average is equal to x of 0 y of 0
and
for
average x
like this
and i need to divide this by the number
of locations
both x and y
so when i do this now and i return
this
oh i'm not calling this anywhere
so back in index.js where we have here
the locations i'm also going to get
the
average
location like this
and that's going to be
what i'm going to log next
so we have not a number there
because
the locations is empty
oh yeah and then it's dividing this
i don't want not a number there
so here if we do have locations
if we have locations then i'm going to
do that
otherwise
i just don't
so now what i want to do
is use this location of this marker here
to connect it to these sliders there
so this info value of the slider and
this attribute was x and y right so if i
just
send update points
if i just send update points with
something that has a value
between
minus 0.5 and plus 0.5
so
if i go here and say
value is going to be
average dot x minus
image data width
divided by 2
and
divided by
image data width so this is going to
give me a value
for x
so now what this will mean is
how far is the marker from the center
screen
you will see
and i did the same thing for the y as
well
so let's put here
y like this
and
average y
image data height
like this
and let's now instead of that value
log
x and y from here
so
now this is close to zero
and this one there
still zero on x but the y is big and now
the y is
negative
okay i think i'm
making some mistakes here
is this average calculated correctly
let's go back here and
print what we had previously
i didn't really look at those numbers
before
so
they are flipped
x and y are flipped
yes
this is why this is x
okay and here
now
the new x and y values after scaling
them
yes so here x is close to minus 0.5
x is
plus 0.5
y is plus 0.5
y is minus 0.5
and
now that we have this x and y value here
i'm just going to call
update
points
with something that has a value
of x
and
x so
here update points was waiting for this
attribute of x and y
and the same thing with
y
and y there
okay
i like it
uh this recognizing this blue color
needs a bigger threshold maybe or
not great but uh
testing like this is sure is easier now
and uh
if i'm gonna put this on my
in my head or something tomorrow then
yeah
i think i can make this
somehow
uh move with my head if i put some kind
of markers on the face
so i'm gonna
do something like that tomorrow
and i'm gonna think about it while i'm
walking home
i'm back
and
i would really want to get this
character talking as well somehow
depending on what i do with with my
mouth
so
maybe i will have many markers on the
face or something let's see
but
this is somehow quite nice already
i'm happy with this
um
not perfect
and some things feel a little bit
strange
but
let's see how the hair will adjust and
how the hair will fix some of the things
and so on
yeah
okay
see you tomorrow
it's the next day now and i'm walking to
work and
i've been thinking what will happen
today and
it's going to be a very different day
because yesterday i had no idea what's
going to happen we didn't even know what
project we're going to start
but now
i'm going to begin with
some more code refactoring i'm going to
change everything to be
as object-oriented as possible because
now functions are floating everywhere
and if you want to import this in your
own project it's
it's a chance that something is gonna
conflict with something else so
not good
and
doing this refactoring stage in the
beginning is also great because i'm not
going to remember all the things that
i've been doing yesterday
then next thing what i'm going to do is
implement some physics i'm going to use
this verlai integration technique
because i've used it so many times and i
think i remember it
and what i'm gonna do with that is
eventually do the hair
but uh
that
image of myself that i drew a long time
ago initially had things like this
around the around the neck and that's
what i'm gonna apply the physics on
first uh kind of like a simple pendulum
and then i'm gonna move to the hair
which is gonna be a bit more
a bit more difficult
but anyway uh physics for that so i will
start with some kind of
utility functions for
doing linear algebra i'm gonna need some
help for that and
then
a little bit of physics
and
last i'm gonna
do
some basic
image processing and this is going to
happen so that
i'm going to have markers on my face
so there will be
markers
on the face area they're going to be
around the mouth somehow so that it can
change the drawing based on how i'm
opening my mouth i hope that's going to
work i'm going to also use some
reference point here so that the head
movement like this is going to be picked
up
i didn't have any
great markers at home so i took with me
a double-sided tape
which should hold on to things i hope
it's gonna hold on to
my face especially because i have the
beard
and um
[Music]
it's white so i also took one of the
blue markers that i've used in many of
the videos
to color
color them i really hope the detection
is gonna be good i'm going now to a
different room so the lighting there is
better
and i don't think i'm gonna have a big
problem with that but detecting the
all those points and figuring out what
the face should do it's probably gonna
be a challenge let's see
[Applause]
so
the physics is something that i'm gonna
start with and then this face detection
thing i also have scissors because i'm
gonna need to cut that tape somehow
good that i don't forget things like
that
yeah so physics and then that
uh
face detection thing
according to the markers
and i'm gonna do those immediately when
i arrive because i want to be as fresh
as possible for the heavy stuff
and then whatever fine tuning i can
still
manage
will happen afterwards
so maybe something like that knows that
i don't like how it looks like i have
some ideas
about it maybe using transparency on
that line and making some new lines
appear as the face is moving we'll
we'll see
but yeah so
uh
heavy things at first
and uh at some point i'm gonna need a
way to toggle between
between using
the sliders as the input because i want
to have users able to somehow play
around with the avatar
even if they don't have a webcam
and the webcam and then the third thing
that i want to do is
record uh a small video of me saying
something like hi i am produce avatar
and maybe test a few movements uh
talking and moving the head
so that one will be the default when you
enter the page um a video playing
of myself with the markers
and um
the
avatar is going to hopefully do the
things that i'm doing at the same time
and from that you can change to the
webcam but you need some kind of way to
mark the face
like that
and um
if not then you can change to some
um
to just use the sliders there so maybe
i'm gonna use a drop down simple drop
down for that or um
radio box
is
or something
anyway
that's the plan so
refactoring oop
um
physics
[Applause]
face detection
i mean face pose detection using the
markers
and
uh a better interface and the video for
that
so hopefully the first two happen before
my
lunch break
i also have another meeting
and then the other two happen afterwards
and uh
yeah
i'm gonna have about
six more hours to put into this i think
so let's see
okay i'm in a new room now and the
lighting is much better here
so now when i use the marker which i
took from home
it's going to be
detected much better than
yesterday when i tried to do this so now
i can move the character
with this blue
blue marker here in the screen so i will
probably have something like this on my
on my head and adjust this
somehow and i really want to do
something with the mouth as well so
let's see later but first
a little bit of refactoring and i'm
going to make this character here
using object-oriented programming
so
let me go
to
index html
and
what i want to do here
instead of draw me i'm going to say
something like
uh
avatar
draw
on
on the context
so i'm going to give the context here as
a as an argument
and this avatar is going to be an avatar
object so i'm going to define this in an
avatar
js
file
class
avatar
like this
and
i will give it the constructor
and the draw method
so now um
the code in this draw me is going to
move
inside of the avatar's draw method
and
context goes here
in case you want to use multiple avatars
multiple canvases something like that
right and this draw me is not
needed anymore but we need to define
this avatar so we are going to say
avatar
new avatar
here
as a global
variable
good
and
draw body and draw head these are going
to change to be
methods inside of the avatar and they
will be private methods so i'm going to
say this dot
hashtag draw body and same for this draw
head
so let's do the body first it's going to
be
this function from here i remove it
and
i put it here
as a method the drawbody method and the
ctx should be passed here as well so
that the body knows where to draw itself
so it begins the path
um this a point is a global
variable and that's something i don't
like
we are going to need to pass this
down to
the avatar so it knows where it should
be looking at
so a actually stands for that point that
avatar was was directing its
head at
let's see the other code for the draw
head and i'm going to
have to copy everything from here
this whole file
goes also in the avatar class
and
it needs to become
methods
as well
so these functions will also be
converted into methods into private
methods actually and they will need
access to this context so i need to pass
it down so
private methods because it's its own
responsibility the avatar knows how to
draw itself
and these points are going to somehow
be important because they are coming
from outside they are coming from
the code that processes the camera here
or they are coming from sliders here
which currently i don't think work
or
oh they do work
uh if there is no blue in the screen
uh
then
they seem to work which is quite nice
so i'm gonna have also some kind of
toggling between how to move this
character around
so um
b and c are really not much used i think
yeah they are just used for the colored
shape
of the head
colored with the skin color
i wanted to have different ideas for
that i wanted to
somehow
use more this interpolation
and
these ranges here but when i saw that
it's becoming somehow tricky to do and i
added there some negative range
to make something work with c i realized
that it's somehow
uh
becoming too confusing so i did
everything relative to point a and the
other ones i think we may not even need
them let's let's see
but let me finish this code now so
uh
draw years
all of these things here they need to
become
method calls
and private methods there's no real
reason for the outside
coders from the outside this class to be
able to call this
method
and
same here with the draw year
now and
all of these that are
taking a here they need also the context
now so let's
pass already the context there
in addition to this reference point
to all of these things
so context will be will be needed there
right
and um
method
here
looks good
so
let's go down to this
drawn nose
and make this one as a method as well
our to do is there
if time at the end i will do those fine
tunings
the draw here it's going to be draw half
here
like that and
these
need the ctx as well
now
and here
yeah looks good
drawbeard
also private method this time
so doing the code like this means that
we are
we can include this avatar class and we
don't have to worry if somebody else has
a function called draw half beard
somewhere
so very useful
um
in separating the code and making it
um
not interfere with with other things
draw half beard
and i'm also relearning what i did
yesterday so that i don't
so that i know where i'm at pretty much
okay
so only problem now i think
i don't need anymore this body js and
this
head js let me delete these
like so
and
in index html i'm going to have to
include avatar js instead
and i think it should still be able to
access the global points from here but
i'm gonna do something about that let's
refresh
errors
for some reason it complains about this
context there
let's put the breakpoint and
undefined
inside of this
draw year
oh i forgot here to pass
ctx
okay good
yeah so
much better
i think
but these points are something i don't
really like very much so
first of all i'm really curious can we
do without them
somehow let's activate these points
again to be able to
to see them
where they are
and do they really move that much or
could we do them relative to a in some
way
so c is actually
i think b doesn't move
almost at all
so maybe i could replace b
i could maybe remove b in the beginning
and just try replacing it with these
values this value here
let's see
i just delete it from there
and
from here
and inside of this avatar
uh we use be
here
so how about we just put
0 and minus 0.77
does this still look good
b is not
defined oh draw point b i don't want to
draw that point
okay here there is a problem
here there is no problem
so how about we just make it a little
bit lower
like um
like this
we don't need b anymore great
and c is
looks very much like that the bottom
point of the
beard
it was relative to a
let's see so when we draw the head and
we draw the beard here
we have the draw half beard
and
bottom most point so this point
quite complicated it comes also from
this vertical scaler i think
but not impossible to figure out so
let me copy this here
and
when we have the vertical scaler so this
means
um
this one right here
so the bottom most point is actually
this
something like that
and this is
c pretty pretty much so let me just have
here
uh
b
and c
like that so they are not global anymore
they are going to be just these local
ones and i
put here
be like that
so
i remember what they are but
they are not so important that they
deserve drawing in the first place and
definitely they don't deserve to be
global variables a is an exception
because it's going to be controlled by
the sliders and this marker
so c here is going to be
okay
b dot x
b dot
y so i'm going to use this everywhere so
that i don't have the same
hard coded values repeating themselves
the others are important to be like that
because they define the shapes
and here c is going to be
no comma there
i think like that and
i believe this is correct
i'm going to
stop drawing c
and
in the beginning
i just have a there now
whoa something happened
oh
oh
ref is
actually a
in that case so
c is defined according to the a
y offset
okay something bad is happening there
haha it was first translating to ref
yes so um
we without translation i just first i
just have to add the
a coordinates there
so
a dot x
a dot y
plus this one
okay not exactly sure why it's happening
like that but it's almost correctly it's
almost correct so it needs to be
hmm
so in the draw beard
we translate today and then we draw half
beard
oh it's doing some scaling there oh so
complicated
yeah this scaling is also there
complicated complicated stuff
and
[Music]
scale y is just the y offset
so
a dot y offset
like that
one minus that
okay
i think that
this needs to be multiplied by
this
no
maybe
divided by that
no
um
[Music]
i think everything here needs to be
multiplied by that
yes
okay so now we don't need those things
anymore and just that a point is
controlling the head
and
i would also like to clean up
even this a bit more
um
i mean
this avatar class here is quite
big now
so maybe i would like to
extract these
methods somehow
let's try to export extract the eyes
draw eyes
let's see if we can say
this
right eye
draw
and then
give these
things there
like so
and
same for the left eye so i'm gonna
define an eye object
i don't think i need two of them
and
it can be a private
attribute here
okay so let's now here in the top say
this i is new i
class
i
and draw the draw method
it's gonna be
[Music]
this one from here
so it's gonna have a scale and the
context on which to draw it
and
i think that's pretty much it
empty constructor here
so
if i refresh now
i get some errors
is there something wrong with the
private attribute
okay i'm not sure what's wrong with that
but
let's just leave it public it's not the
big deal there
okay so
the eyes
don't work properly
what happened here did i do some
bad thing
oh there was a minus
did i
lose this minus at some point
yes now it looks good
so with the i like that i'm going to
take it out i'm going to put it in i.js
like this
and
i could do the same for others but i
think i'm spending too much time for
refactoring
let's go to index.js and
import
i js as well
so
now everything works
as before but the code is better it has
the eye here in its own class
so
next there would be this
beard
with the draw half beard
so i think i'm gonna try to do it
let's
go where the draw beard is and say
this
beard
draw
using a and the context
so
at the top here
this beard
is new beard
beard js
i'm just going to copy i
class and say here beard
and
i don't need this draw beard anymore
draw beard is going to go inside of the
beard
object
and
it's going to become the draw method
like this
and draw half beard is still going to be
a private method here inside i think
there's no way around that
we need it here
so that's good
and here in the alpha tar
nothing else needed i just need to
import
beard
like this
so code is better
much better
now
next thing uh
i think nose doesn't necessarily need
its own class it's small enough
year is small enough i think
here
this will be needed
because
because i'm going to make it very
complicated soon
so here js and here i'm going to take
out draw hair and draw half hair
and it's already kind of complicated it
says
it's as complicated as the beard so i'm
gonna take these
methods out from here
and put them here
let's copy the beard
code
and
just replace with this one
probably
i wasted more time copying that but
somehow
and the draw here in the same way
yes no problems with that
so the beard also will need to be
defined somewhere
i mean
hair did i say beard
okay
right
so
avatar js has
not so many lines anymore
has the body drawing and then this is a
debug thing
that um
maybe i'm going to actually make it like
that
if i want to debug then i'm going to
show these points
i may have multiple ones
later and in index here i can have a
debug
true
so now if this is true then the points
are showing if this is false then the
points are not showing
so i don't need to comment out things
all the time
and here
[Music]
this a point is something that i need to
fix
it doesn't mean anything i'm
i don't think i'm gonna need anything
else just a point where it's looking at
so let's just call it
look at and i will make a comment here
point a
when we debug so this look at is
a point
like this
and
this a here
won't be needed anymore so i'm gonna
remove it and we will just
use
look at
everywhere
and when we define the avatar
i'm going to give it this
look at
point as a reference
so
now
here
this is going to be a so where is it
looking at
every time we have a capital a so i'm
gonna look for it matching the case and
there's a full word
every time we have this kind of capital
a i'm gonna replace it with this dot
look at
that one can stay like that
it's the label and drawing the point
with our
utility function
okay
saving
and here
we have that update
points function
so this was the thing that
moves with the slider so
update
look at
update look at
update look at
and
i don't need the for loop here anymore i
just have
p equals to
look at
so
right
refresh
allow
no
error when the
camera because i still have update
points here so update look at the value
of x and the value of y
yes okay finally
finally code is now
as clean as i'm going to get it in this
project it's
not all about the code quality i think
code quality is very important and i
don't want to give some bad
bad
example to anybody
everything can always be improved but
you need to stop somewhere also in real
work
okay
done
it's
much better now at least
yes
so uh next what we are gonna do is
physics
so let's let's do the physics next and
i'm going to
go quite quickly
through these things i've i've done them
multiple times and i have an idea how
they're gonna go
yeah
so let's have a
file
physics js and in index.js
include this one as well
okay
and
i'm actually going to start with adding
some more utility functions so
there will be some math functions
that work with the
vectors because i make mistakes if i
don't use vectors when i'm doing the
physics it's just so much easier when
you work with
x and y combined or i usually like
vectors to be
using arrays so i have the array of 0
and array of 1. it's very useful because
then i can use for example
this function here that works with
arrays
this could have also been with that so
now i have a mess of
points and also these kind of 3d points
are different they don't have xyz but
yeah it's a little
bit i should refactor this so here the
location
i prefer to use arrays everywhere so
instead of an object with x and y it's
going to be
a vector with
zero zero here
yes
it's just much better when the code is
more
is consistent everywhere and because we
are using 3d here also for the color
space
it makes sense to
have it like this these functions become
more general
yeah
so we have the average and we are using
this average somewhere in
index
i think
no in camera
no not in camera where is the average
being used
it it is an index
some oh i have these things on
um
yes so here
average of zero and average of
one
and um
i don't
think i need this logging anymore and
this
comment from here
let's
try again
yeah good everything still works
so where was i
utility functions for more more vector
operations
so i just they are simple they are just
for
vector addition so for example you have
two vectors here like that and
you can implement this by just
considering 2d vectors but i really like
to go and
say
um
the new vector like the result
is like that and
go through all the elements so it would
work in any dimensions
like this
like so and return this new vector
like this so this is for adding vectors
now
subtracting vectors
we also need things like
magnitude of a vector so
essentially the
length of a vector
or just one vector here so i'm going to
say
this magnitude
this is the same thing as the distance
from zero
so i think that i can actually reuse
that function here and say
return
distance
of
v
and an array of zeros
so
new array of the size of
the
[Music]
filled with zeros i think is the syntax
i hope
this will work so the magnitude is
how far from zero this is pretty much
and
we can reuse that function there
and also very important function
is to be able to normalize
so you just get
essentially a vector with a length of
one
any kind of input vector you just get
output something with the length of one
but it keeps the orientation
or scaling
to
scale is also important so scale let's
let's actually do this
scaling first and then we do the
normalization so when you scale
something you need the vector but the
other one is going to be a scalar of
a simple number
and i'm going to do this by going
through
these elements and each element
multiplied by the scalar like this
and now normalizing
is just
a return
scale of the v with 1 divided by the
magnitude of v so you divide it by its
length and you end up with the value of
1 for the new magnitude
so simple relatively simple things i i
think and they are now
more
vector utility
functions
i can separate these a little bit
so this is now general drawing here
let's call these
vector map
and
this is something to do
with and that
let's move linear interpolation here as
well it's
quite related i think
and
the last one was
just drawing things general very general
things so now our utility functions are
more of them we have more utility
functions now and the the physics that i
want to implement are going to be
do i have some error
here
i don't think so
okay
oh there is some error somewhere
here
i copied that
so it's everywhere
okay nothing broke
i just added new code so in the physics
everything will be based on
it will be based on particles so this
verla integration method i want to
implement
works well with particles and then with
some constraints like
sticks between the particles
so
class particle
then
here i'm going to put it at some
location so
each particle will be initialized
somewhere let's say
location like this
and
store it
and when particles move it's useful to
keep also the old location in memory it
will be useful in the mathematics so i'm
just going to initialize this with the
same location in the beginning so the
particle doesn't move from some past
last
place
and
we need to be able to draw this
so i'm just gonna do simple things like
begin path and then
let's make these red
so they stand out and we easily
recognize them
or actually orange i think it's better
red than green like the green shirt
color is sometimes confusing to people
so
uh
let's
just
make a small circle there at the
location
since these are going to be vectors
i can say here location of 0 and
location of 1 or i can just
spread the location object like this
and give it the radius
say
0.1
and um
the arc method works like that so
i need to specify there
the full circle and
these need to
update
according to some kind of forces so
usually we have some gravity
i don't want to leave these as global
variables here but
let's see later
so
just some value for the gravity there
and this would actually need to be a
vector
and since we're in 2d space i'm going to
say
0 horizontally and 0 vertically like
that and the update
so what i'm going to do now is pretty
much first figure out if the location if
the particle is moving
from its old location somehow so i'm
going to get a
velocity vector
by doing a
subtraction from this location to this
old location
like that and i can predict the new
location
to by adding
to this location
the velocity vector that we just
calculated so where it came from where
it's now
you get that difference the vector
connecting them and you add it to the
current location to get the new one but
you're not done yet because then you can
still add this gravity for example so
this actually needs to change
and we say new location is equal to add
to new location we add the gravity
vector
and
we also have to update now
old location to be equal to this
location
like that so we don't lose it and now we
can update this location to
new
location that we calculated previously
so i use the extra variable there so
that
i can still keep the previous one and i
don't change it
instantly there
okay
so with this kind of particle here and
an update and then draw method i'm going
to go to the avatar
and uh
here i'm going to
just try adding a particle where it's
looking at
yeah
so
let's see
this
part
particle new particle
at
look at
this is with x y because it's in pixels
so i'm gonna say
this
look at
x and this look at
why i'm converting it into an array here
and
i don't think i need to give it anything
else and now here in the draw method i'm
going to
[Music]
say this particle
draw on the context like so
so if i refresh
i get errors
okay
oh wow
i think this location might be a kind of
a
reserved word
and this is uh
or maybe not let's
i think i'm missing this there
yes i think now it should work let's see
okay
so
we see now this particle
um
initialized where
a where that look at point
is in the beginning but it's not a
reference to it i'm
taking its x and y initially when it's
initialized and then
it stays there the particle
um
i think i'm gonna make the particle look
a little bit different so
let me go here and say
i will make it red so i will make it a
smaller radius
3 and
stroke
it will be red
but i'm also going to
[Music]
make a stroke to it that is going to be
white
so that
you can see it
better
okay i think this is good
so that's the particle but it's not
falling i said it should fall with the
gravity but we are never calling this
update function so
here
let's call this particle
update first and see what happens
something happens it's not there anymore
i think it might have moved very quickly
because
this
scene is in such a small
or i don't know
what is happening there
this number is becoming huge all of a
sudden
and this becomes infinity so what what
gives
let me debug this velocity vector here
something strange is happening no matter
what the gravity is
these numbers become big and small i
mean
negatively big let me go to the utils
maybe i made some mistakes here with the
vectors so
oh subtract this minus
probably this is it let's
save
okay and now the point
is falling
and it's actually accelerating
it's falling faster and faster and
faster and that's great
so i would like to
do a couple of things here
[Music]
and i will start with this
let me show you the picture
we had previously there like that so
these things here are missing right now
and they actually
used to be
um
in my original drawing they used to be
something hanging from there
so i would like to make those
move a little bit as the character is
moving
so
um
when he moves left to right like this i
want it to fee
to move a little bit like a pendulum
so i'm going to put one particle here
and one particle here i'm going to make
this one up the one up static and the
one at the bottom
it will be constrained to be at the
fixed distance from the top one
so
let's first define these particles and
um
actually uh i'm just going to define
another one
beneath this one
so
let's add a function here
i will refactor this at some point
but
update particles and this is now going
to
let's put draw particles as well it's
it's nicer like that and here we have
particles
is equal to
an array so the first item in this array
is going to be
one particle at that look at
and
the other item in this array is going to
be another particle that is somewhere
below that so
in the beginning
i just do something easy like this
so below the first particle and now what
i'm going to do here is for
this particles
for each
particle i'm going to loop through all
of them and say
update these particles and then i'm
going to say
draw
these particles
on the context so
here this method will need that
and
i'm going to say here this
update
particles and
this draw particles
like this
so this should now
let's go back to our
code this should now show two particles
that are just falling like that but the
first one i want it to be static so i
think i wanted to
fix it somehow to
i will add the third parameter let's
call it true and i'm going to
fix it to
is fixed so i
i won't allow it to move
like this
and in the update
none of this needs to happen if it's
fixed so if is
this is fixed
return
i think this is fine and i don't need to
log the velocity anymore that was just
for debugging there
so now
what happened
where is one particle
um
no i don't think this is
this is not the problem
what happened
so back in the avatar i have
oh i'm passing here
inside the array and i think it had
consequences
okay so back here
if it's fixed i don't have to update
so this one is fixed there
right
okay
so that one is fixed but the other one
is not so what we need to do now is uh
constrain the other particle
to
uh
the first one so for that i'm gonna
implement here a segment class
that will have a fixed length and this
segment will be between two particles so
i'm just gonna
say here a constructor for
a and b
and
i will say here
okay
i don't want to confuse a and b with the
way i'm talking about those a b points
from previously i think it's it's clear
enough
i'm going to save a here and say
now let's just say
particle a
particle b
okay and let's calculate the distance
between these two particles so i'm going
to say a length for this segment
is equal to the distance between
particle a
location
and particle b
location like this
and
i think that's all i need to know about
this segment it's initial length when
it's defined
and then to draw this segment i'm going
to use a context and i'm just going to
do
this
a simple line i think i'm going to do a
red line just
to debug for now
so
ctx
begin path
ctx
stroke style
red
ctx move to
this particle
a location
and here i can
spread these into two values because the
move two needs two values
and line two particle b location
like this
i have a message
okay
oh wait there was another
right
so
um
stroke
like this and
the segment
needs to be created also somewhere so
here let's say
this segment
i pre i prepare it to be an
array already
is a new segment
with
particles of 0 and this dot particles of
one so the ones we defined previously
like this
and uh i also i'm also gonna need
update segments
but all of these are the same all of
these have update and draw update and
draw
so
maybe it shouldn't be update particles
and update
and draw particles but
update
and draw
we already have a draw
update
items and
physics item
and draw physics item
and this is going to be a parameter so
items
and the context there so here
i'm gonna have to change these
like so
i i'm gonna reuse this same code to
handle the segments and the particles so
here update physics items
and
draw physics items
first i'm going to give this
particles
and then i'm gonna give this particles
here
but after we do that
i'm gonna give this segments
this segments
and
i don't have yet the update for the
segments yet so let me comment it out
and just see if this code still works
um
not in an array here
these are just two arguments
okay so now you can see also the red
line but this is not a segment i mean it
is a segment that is changing length but
uh
it should be like a stick so our update
method here inside of the
segment class it needs to
constrain it to the initial length when
it was defined so i'm going to say here
update
and let's just see
what the new length is first so
it's going to be we subtract
from
this particle a location
to this
particle b
location so this is
the difference between
a and b and currently
and i'm gonna need the magnitude of this
so how
i mean
so far we we actually
have the vector difference
yeah and the magnitude of this is going
to be
magnitude of
like this
and
we need the difference between the two
magnitudes so how much do we need to
relocate the particles so that they are
still close to
as close as in the beginning here so the
difference between this magnitude and
this initial length
so
is going to be magnitude minus this
length like this
and
i'm also going to need
it's going to be easier if i also get
the normalized vector between these two
because then i can scale that
in both directions and
and fix the segment if it gets too long
or too
too short
so i'm gonna do here
the normalizing
vector
normalized vector by normalizing this
d vector so now the length is going to
be 1 after this but it's not going to be
losing its orientation
okay
so now what we can do
is um
move a and b
locations of a and b
with this difference with half this
difference
in each direction so
this particle a location is going to be
let's add so let's add to the current
this particle a location
we can scale the normalized vector from
above
with
minus the difference
by two so i'm moving um
one point by half
and i have to think about also these
fixed points later the ones that
don't move but let's just do this now
and hope it works
and the same thing for b
but
plus here so one goes if the segment is
longer than it should be
this point goes half the difference that
way and this goes half the difference
that way if it's shorter then it goes
half the difference have the difference
opposite direction so something like
that
great
i hope
i really think this is going to break
refresh it's not broken but it's not
doing oh i'm not
calling this
here because we didn't have an update
method previously
normalizing is not defined
i think it's called normalize
i was just talking what i'm doing
okay
and now this point is
there
interesting that this other one doesn't
oh it does move
it
if you look closely you can see this one
is actually falling very very slowly
and that's because
this one is pulling on it so it's going
down a little bit and then this segment
stretches and then both of these points
adjust because
here we have
we are moving each of them even if point
a
should be fixed actually
so i'm gonna need to
take care of this somehow so this code
is fine if the points are not fixed so
if for example
this particle a
is fixed
if it's not fixed and
this particle b
is not fixed
then this is just fine code here
but otherwise
if
a is not fixed
then a is going to move
twice that difference so it's going to
do all the work so to
speak else
it means b is the one that is not fixed
i don't need this if statement i think
so
what happens if both are fixed
so if these are not fixed if a is not
fixed
if b is not fixed
let's just be careful here and
if b is not fixed then b is gonna move
with both of them
i mean uh with double the
um
yeah
but uh
if both of them are fixed
then nothing should happen i think this
is this should work
i hope
so if i refresh now
i think this point doesn't move anymore
but so far
there's nothing fancy happening here so
what i want to do now is
fix this point to something maybe i'm
going to fix it to the
a location so
let's say here this particles of zero so
this point from there is gonna be
this dot
look at at each time we are drawing
um
actually i need to do to look at x and
this look at
y
converting to an array from this point
of pixel point object
now
it's breaking
the
location
of the particle
zero has to be like that
okay and now
this gravity is
is too weak
i
i want it to be stronger so
physics gravity
okay
so now when it's moving
um
that segment uh always constrains the
bottom particle the particle wants to go
down then when you move to the side it
wants to stay there its original
position but then that segment is going
to pull it
somehow so now i'm i'm getting
pretty much exactly what i want but
that's not where we're gonna put this so
yeah i
let's let me try to swing it like a
like a swing
like give it
momentum when i should give it momentum
and
this is fun okay it's going more and
more
okay
um
i want this to be somewhere here
attached to the
body
so that's gonna be
this is gonna happen in the draw body
thing
yeah and then we are gonna use these
same things for the hair as well
so
[Music]
let's go back here and actually
i would like to have in the avatar
a body as well
this all the because men much code is
going to be their new body
and
hope this is not a re reserved word
so
bode.js and let's include it here as
well
like this
and then both djs
might be a reserved word but let's see
so
uh
draw body
is gonna be just a method in class
body
that is called
draw like this
and the shirt color
let's actually pass it here
uh
i also need the skin tone
so we don't use global variables at this
stage
okay
shirt color and skin tone
okay so this is now body and inside of
avatar
i
all the
draw
on the context
okay
look at
needs to be passed here as well
because the
body is also adjusting a little bit with
that
so
draw
with this
this look at
okay why is it red
oh i'm not passing the colors here
when creating the body i should use
shirt color
skin tone
these should be also passed here in the
avatar when creating the avatar
to avoid
issues
great okay
it works
so
now i really want to
add these particles
not in the avatar
but in the
body
and
i think this is just
fine to copy here
but the code here for
updating the physics items drawing the
physics items
and these things here
this needs to be extracted in the
physics
file here so i'm going to make a class
physics
and i think i'm going to use static
variables so static functions so i'm
going to
write here
physics
update physics items
draw physics items probably this draw
should be
not in physics but in some
drawer or whatever
but this is just fine
and
these go out from there
to here with static because we don't
initialize this object
and i think this is where the gravity
goes as well
so
static
gravity there
and
the particle takes it from physics
it's better like this
a little better it's not perfect but
i didn't really know what i'm gonna do
with this
so let's
remove this and
inside of the body
after we do all the other drawings i'm
gonna put here
this code
yeah
save this refresh and an error
okay the
look at is
no longer with this here i'm passing it
like that
hmm
i'm just gonna put zero zero for now
zero plus zero three i don't need the
look at
in that way at least so
let's just
have it zero zero
mm-hmm
um
why aren't they appearing
um
why is it not appearing there
it should appear right
i know
this location is not good
it's under the head
it was under the head
oh boy
yeah
okay
so
so it's drawing it there
but i really want to use this look at
point somehow so
let's first move it to
location there so it was
where was it
somewhere here
so
let me put it actually somewhere
lower
so
let's put
93 here
i think this is
let's see if we can use these values
because i don't remember what
here
yes
no
it's not exactly
a bit higher up let's say seventy
five
71
like this and
now it's
it's there but it's not affected by the
physics because the drawings that are
happening here
are
not
i don't like
uh
not here
we go with these back
in the avatar and draw them on top of
that otherwise this is just a squishing
squishing effect there
so let's go to avatar and
put them back here
and the it's okay that we did this in
the body it's no problem it's very good
but i want this to be at the higher
level
so here in the draw
i'm going to say
that
okay
and
now
this location should be even higher i
think
65.
okay it's almost good 64.
yes 64. and this is the center point so
now um
i need to figure out how much this point
should move left and right according to
these
translations and these scalings here
so
only the x location changes so
i call this a string now i'm gonna call
this thing string
so let's say
string x is going to be equal to
i mean
let's
call it string location and the x is
going to be equal to
this value
and
y is going to be equal to this value
but
we need to
we need to
modify so first what we do is we
translate
this by that so that just means
plus that value
and then when we are at the location
i'm going to scale with this
let's say
x translate
this
and this
like so
and uh here plus
x translate
times this x scale
it should be fine and i'm not repeating
the variables there anymore i really
hope i didn't mess something up
okay
it's doing it
it's it's doing it i don't want this to
be anything like an in your face effect
but
i want it to do
what it's it's doing there
so
great i
i like it
let's do the same thing on the right
side
i just want to get the things working
now i i will style these better at the
end somehow
and the code is now not great yet but
it will become better i think
so i need more particles here
this is actually the main location of
the
yeah
this is the main location of the string
so let's call this
this
string location
initial string location
and
this one is going to be
that
okay
and um
this
this
with this in front
otherwise like now if i re
well i broke it but uh
when you initialized everything was kind
of
spinning in place because the initial
location was not that
that we were forcing it to be but then
um
in the first second it teleports
somewhere else and it forces the spin to
happen
in it
okay
yeah great and
we have another one on the right
let's put this one on the right
oh
yeah because it's not symmetric we i
drew this kind of free form shape
okay
then let's have two of them
or
right and left
i think i'm going to make a string
object eventually
but
let's just see how how
much software engineering do i need to
use
let's do it
left string
initial location
this one
particles
an array
segments
an array
segments should be with these particles
and i'm not sure how to access these
from here
i don't think this code works
i
may need to extract this as a formal
class
but no problem
let's see
so left string let's put the right
string and we'll adjust it later
okay
so this is now
right string
and here
left string particles
left string segments
left string particles of zero
is equal to and i'm just going to do the
calculation here directly
so
it's going to be this dot left string
initial location
x
plus the translate
times the scale and the second one is
going to be just the value of y
i don't think this will work
but
needs to be done anyway
yeah it doesn't work so let me extract
this as uh
as another class
string and thread are called both words
that mean something else
hanging string
okay
and
in the constructor
we give it an initial location
so this init lock is in it
and
now particles and segments can be here
like i can write it like this like that
this particles is equal to a new
particle with this initial location
these segments
is going to be
an array with just one segment
and these
particles
okay and now i have this left string
equals new hanging string
of this initial location
thing there
and
probably now it's going to work
right string with the plus there
no
it doesn't work
so a hanging string with these locations
left string particles
location is
left string initial location plus
blah blah
some undefined particles
so i'm passing it here
the left string
initial location
oh dot y
i hope it's this
whew it's that
great
let's give it a draw method
an update method and the draw method
so
in the update method i want to
[Music]
put the location of the first particle
to something
something like that so where is the
attachment coming from so
or
no i just give it the translate and the
scale it's a little bit confusing but
yeah
so this x translate and scale
will be sent to that and it's going to
use
these particles of zero and this initial
location like this
it's not that confusing because that's
how we are updating the the body there
so
it's okay
so now i'm going to say here
this left
string update
uh x translate x scale
and
for the right string
i'm going to do
the same
thing
maybe
let's also
update the physics after that
like that
and
draw the things
i have draw for that now
so i'm going to say
draw the particles
and draw the segments
i also need to update the segments
yeah so
a little bit confusing what i did maybe
but
so now i'm updating those that one and
i'm gonna draw it this one
on the context and same for the one on
the right and hopefully this works now
okay
i think it's okay but the one on the
right needs to be lower so
even more
even more
okay and the bottom part can be even off
the screen so
something like that
i
i will style this a bit later but look
at it now so one is moving one way the
other one is moving a little bit
different
i really like this this
effect now
so
about the styling we will look at later
now what i'm gonna do is
the hair
so
i'm gonna try to make
strings like that
here in the front so hanging somehow in
the front and these are
going to move and then maybe i'm going
to do the same in the back i have longer
hair now
so maybe i don't worry about this top
part just yet but here i want some hair
to appear like this
so let's
let's try
see how our
code is at the moment
like
yeah basically i i want to know
if this code is good enough
i think it is at least for now so the
string left and string right
actually
let's call this pendulum it's it's much
better
it's a much better name so pendulum
uh
like this
yeah and let's extract it in pendulum
js
pendulum js
like this
and
here
in index i'm going to include
pendulum js
so everything still works now and the
hair is going to be pendulum as well so
made out of different pendulums
maybe we make double pendulums chaotic
pendulums let's see if enough time
but
i think that
code is
decent at the moment
a little bit too many things here but i
think
fifth of them will go away because they
are not
needed for
actual
things
all right so
i want now to
get back this code where i click
and i get the chord and it's without the
look at
translation
and um
figure out some locations here in the
beginning to put the hair
so something like
this location
this this this this something like that
so i just clicked there to something
that looks good but i prefer to have it
not exact so that it doesn't look too
symmetric
and
these locations are going to be things
where
i'm going to
add more pendulums so let's say
this
front
here
is going to be an array of pendulums so
new pendulum
of
x and y
something
and these will need to be
figured out somehow depending on the
sliders
but anyway
one step at a time
so now this
value from here
from here
from
here it looks the same
starts to be positive
thing one
all right
so
uh
yeah many pendulums in the front here so
what do we do with them
we update them so for
this pendulums
for each
pendulum
i'm going to say
p dot update
according to something i'm gonna put x
translate
and one at the beginning just to test
some basic things but uh
it will be different i'm sure
so that's what happens first and then
p dot draw on the context so each of the
hair pendulums
uh front hair not pendulums so
for each front hair pendulum
do this thing
okay
it's horrible
so something happens but
not what it should be
i think
i need to put
something relative to
a translation by a at least
so
something like this but the special
translation for the head so these x and
these are shirts
shirt x translate and shirt
x scale
or body
okay
okay
but i will need
head x translate
actually head translate
and it's gonna need to have a
x and a y
so
and i don't like something i have here
this update with the scale doesn't make
much sense
not at all actually
i will need to revise something here
let's
have another function
update 2
where
it's going to have just an
attach location i wanted to do something
like this before so
i just copy it inside and i say that
this location is going to be
this whatever
attach location that i'm giving
so
if time i have to refactor this
so hit translate
x is going to be
let's just put it um
i can't put it at a
i would like to keep these values
somewhere
maybe each particle is going to
have the initial location kept
let's see if that helps
so
then these numbers are as the initial
location so this is going to be now
this dot look at x
so update 2
yeah for each
head it's different so
update 2 with x to
this look at x plus p
init location
x
and
this is something else not needed
and
it's not needed and the same thing
happens for
y i think
nope
oh
actually
it's not a bad idea
[Music]
hey
we have it already
i didn't need to do that so
i don't need this initial location there
and it's called init lock
i don't like it let me refactor this
like that
okay so max and y goes there by mistake
so the pendulum is defined with an x and
y
okay
and then here
p update
oh this should be an array yes because
we are in the vector place i couldn't
use vectors
i think for the
pixels because
they do have x y
okay
so
let me disable now this
pendulum
this particle logging there it's filling
up the console and i don't want that
okay
okay
it's something it's uh something cool i
like it length needs to be a parameter
and these
points here
maybe they can be a little lower down
so
in the avatar where i'm defining the
first and the last
point i'm gonna put here minus
41.
so now this is lower and the last one
should be also
somewhat lower
maybe 38
good and these lengths i think they can
vary
so in the pendulum the length is set to
this
i put the default of that but here
when defining the avatar it's going to
be
no not that one
this one
second one i think can be 35
i'm giving myself a haircut
let's put this one also a bit lower
this is
fine
okay
this point is too much to the right i
don't like it there so let me put here
34.
good
okay it's it's something interesting
definitely interesting i i like it
um
i would like it to bounce somehow
somehow
uh
let's try to make these as
double pendulums
it's not as hard as it sounds
i think
double pendulum
okay
length divided by two
and
one more particle
that is going to be
with the length so it's going to have a
midpoint here
and the
segments
will be two segments
and
the second one is going to be like that
like that
and uh that's it i think
i just need to go here and replace with
double pendulum
and i get an error a double pendulum is
not defined because i'm not including it
anywhere
okay
it has a different shape
now a little bit different behavior than
before
but somehow i
i think the gravity is maybe too much
maybe even too much
yes
tall and
small but that's what i want
more more of this kind of movement it's
it's great
and because the pendulums have different
lengths then each hair is going to be
behaving differently
okay great i like it
this is awesome
i i like it a lot
so
what i'm gonna do next is uh do the back
hair as well
so the back hair
similar to this i think it's not too
complicated
and
[Music]
then i'm gonna try to make the mouth
move
so
i will keep the hair ugly like this for
now and
think about it later how to get it
better
but
yeah so styling the hair will be the
fine tuning part
so now let me add similar things for the
back here so front hair is there
back here
and
let's have it very similar to this
the same in the beginning
but this needs to be longer maybe
[Music]
just replace these threes with the six
and now the back here
goes through the same things
like this
i refresh
and it's there
but
it should be
in the back
and it should be lower
so let's put here
let's replace this four with the two
this three with the one
i think that's fine and this six with
the seven
okay and the problem now
there are
two problems actually
it should be opposite of what a is doing
so when you move the head up this back
hair has to go down and when you do this
this back hair has to go up
so this back here
i want a reflection here i want to
not the reflection but a
symmetric a point that is symmetric
somehow
this look at
point that we define here in the
beginning
i wanted to have
initial values so
init x
0
init y
minus 0.13
this is not the
best way
the clearest way to do it but
i want to
get this done
so
i keep the same value so that they never
change
and then in the avatar here when we are
moving this so what i want to have here
is a
symmetric point on the other side of
this one so i'm going to say
i don't have the vector operations for x
and y but
so init x and init y are going to just
keep them static right
yes so those
are the initial locations of that a
point so now what i want is
this point here
is the
initial one so i want
this pendulum to move
down here
symmetric with respect to this pendulum
so i have this location and i have this
location
if i subtract
from x
the initial x
i need this vector right here
i think it's like this
i would really like to use the same
operations there that's the vectors but
i think i i could
i just
want to get things done now
maybe have time to refactor this
yeah yeah this is good this is very good
it's just confusing that the
back hair is in front so let me move it
in the back
somehow uh
when we are drawing the head i want
actually behind the body
or i don't know
yeah behind the body also so it's going
to be
here
great
they need to be
longer
and this one is too high up i can see it
there i don't want that
so
the one on the right needs to be
a little bit more to the left
and let's put here eight
okay
let me make everything a bit um
transparent
doesn't work
i don't draw the head
i think
um
it's fine
it's not fine i don't like it i think
the front part it's interesting that
it's like that but the back part those
pendulums are so long
that
and the gravity is so weak that it
affects them in some
not so great way
so what i want to do
is put here a value of
3
and in this update 2
here
gravity multiplier
yes
so
i will pass this to the physics the idea
is that
i want them to be more solid than the
the ones in front i mean not so much
bouncing around
and i just use this trick to get it to
work
of course it's not a realistic
simulation but
this is more about
animation and how things look like and
how they should
look like on
when drawing something so
i don't care about reality
really
and
i'm sending now this gravity multiplier
to
the double pendulum
update physics items
gravity multiplier
gravity multiplier
and the update is going to be
usually it's nothing
but otherwise it's going to be
scaling
g with this gravity multiplier so
yeah by default it's one
and here we are not using the gravity so
we don't need to pass anything to to
this
i think let's save
so the hair in the front is behaving in
one way the hair in the back is behaving
more rigidly if i'm going to put this
avatar to have here maybe 30 then
those hairs in the back are going to be
very very
rigid they are being pulled down so hard
by that
increased gravity
that they are not allowed to move
uh
like the ones in front are jumping there
but i'm not gonna exaggerate so much i'm
just gonna put here maybe
ten
yeah i still want them to move somehow
but
not extreme like
that okay
great
i think i'm gonna take a break and then
what i'm gonna do next is gonna be
the
something with this blue and my face and
i don't like really how that sounds
i hope that i can use this tape somehow
and make some blue markers on the face
and i'm gonna move to do the
mouth
the mouth movements
yes he agrees
good
okay so i'm gonna go have lunch and
continue after that
okay i'm back
and uh we are going to do this mouth
movement next
so i'm gonna begin it by adding a couple
of more sliders one that controls how
the mouth opens like this
like
that and then another one
upwards and
remember only this part of the face
moves actually so this top part of the
mouth is always going to be at the same
same place but
this is
move the down movement is what will
happen
so
i'm going to
just change the shape of the beard here
and this bottom most point
to somehow
be controlled by the sliders and also
this empty space right here
i'm probably not going to draw an actual
mouth i
i hope
i think this empty space might be enough
with the movement of the
chin to give the idea of talking
otherwise
it's more work
so let's see i'm going to go to
index.html
and
i'm going to
put some more sliders here on the right
so i'm going to say
like this
and
i think same settings at the as before
but
update
mouth
and update mouth these will be some new
functions there
so if i refresh
this is fine
and
let's add at the top there something
like
look at
yeah
and um
i think this is better
i'm gonna use capital values and i don't
need um i mean capital letters and i'm
not gonna
need the column anymore i think it's
quite obvious what these are
i think that's good
so um
maybe here it's
it's clear if i put
column on the
right of these words
okay so these need to do something and
update mouth is a function that doesn't
exist so let's go down to
where this one is and um
um
i'm gonna have to pass to
yeah i don't know why i complicated
things
so much with this global variable i
think i'm just going to access the
avatar
and tell the avatar what is the value
and that's it
so
um
like that
so
inside of the avatar i'm going to have a
mouth
um attribute with
0 x and y
and
actually this should be passed down to
the beard as well because
the beard is what is going to change
shape according to these values so
inside of the beard object i'm going to
say here
mouth info
mouth info so some information about the
mouth according to these sliders here
okay
so now when we do this draw half beard
we need to remember
what this
what these shapes are and it's not very
complicated
we were moving
here
and then
doing a curve here
a curve here
and then align to here nothing changes
so much
but now this point will change
so that point
will change according to the mouth x
and then we have
a line to here here
here
all of these three
will change uh with y
so
i'm just gonna guess some scalers for
how much this info is going to affect
and let's see what happens
okay
this month
so this is just going to pass a
reference and every time we change this
object it's going to
should be updated in the beard as well
too much too much way too much
so
here in the beard
let's put um
dot one
maybe it's okay
i think it's okay
and uh vertically
this also needs to be smaller
yeah but i think that actually the this
last
two points here could be a little bit
lower
this 46
i think that's fine
so the mouth is like that and
actually
the bottom most point also needs the
same thing here
so for the y value
um
yeah and let's make some
constants here so
mouth stretch
x
is equal to this amount
and mouth stretch you
so that it's clear
what these things that are also
repeating very much
mean
okay
something is bad here
because when the mouth closes like that
it um
i can see that
bottom point which used to be
c i think
so let me try to fix that i'm gonna go
to
the
avatar
and in draw head
let's try to put this
yeah very complicated function there for
the translations and
almost good
i see that line a little bit and i don't
like it
but um
i don't think i needed a stroke
and then i just see the neck in the
background
yeah
let's see so
and i don't actually need this code
anymore this was just for reference in
the beginning
they were those uh
cross shape thing for the
head i think yeah
and here
what if i just don't do the stroke
it's perfect
i don't see any anything wrong with that
great
okay
good so no need for this
and and
now that i have these controls for the
mouth i'm going to start to do some
image processing here so that the mouth
will
the mouth information comes from
a set of points around the face and
actually the head should also come
from my
movement somehow so i'm thinking
one thing needs to be static somewhere
like a blue point should be here
um
and then
here on the side of the mouth
i need something so
two points here on the sides of the
mouth
they should be quite close to the mouth
so this might be
difficult to place and i have the beard
here it's horrible
and then
one point
also needed here so two points there
one point here
and one point here so maybe then we use
the bottom point
relative to this point to figure out
side to side movement
and uh
no
i don't like that this point is changing
vertically and we might need this
distance for something
like we might need this distance for
um
figuring out how much the head should
move and so on so then if you're talking
like this it might
move your head in unexpected ways later
will it yes
basically
the up and down movement like this it's
the same as if my my mouth opens
so
i need this point for mouth up and down
i also need something static maybe on
the nose
so let's start with the point here and
the point on the nose and see if we get
just the head movement that we have now
and then do that
more sophisticated thing i have a bit of
a worry that this camera here that i'm
using in front is not that good or
let's see
can it recognize very small objects if
um i will have to play with the
thresholds and and things for the image
processing but first i'm gonna take this
tape and i'm going to
cut some things from the tape
so this is double-sided tape and i'm
hoping it will hold
on my face
and i have this marker here that i'm
going to
color it with so that it's blue
i really didn't have it was clo shops
were closed yesterday and i couldn't buy
anything better
i just had this tape at home
so
of course another option would be to
draw on my face
i really hope i don't have to do that
and
i think that the way that collar behaves
on
skin is
not so great
okay something works
so
i made something like this by
coloring some tape on one side and i'm
gonna put
here
i guess
and it's not fantastic because
light reflects from
it
i think it's recognized but sometimes it
may not be recognized
uh
yeah
not much i can do about it i think maybe
i can change the lights somehow in the
room later
but um
let's do tell one on the nose
and i'm gonna look funny for some time
if this stays on my nose
okay
great
i really hope i win this
so
okay some strange movements there
happening
uh
let's move on to
due to
uh the
image processing part so here in index
we were doing something with the video
and
getting the marked locations but i'm not
convinced that this function works that
great
i would like to see the locations on the
canvas here highlighted maybe i'm going
to turn these
blue pixels into
red pixels by
changing the pixel color there
so
let's display them
i'm going to
loop
and now these are vectors actually
so i'm going to loop through them and
say
cam ctx begin path
cam ctx
fill style red
cam ctx
arc
no
just a small rectangle so
wrecked
at the location so i can
spread
the location of i
and one pixel one pixel for the width
and the height
and
fill
so now i'm debugging
the small canvas there
to see
these are red
not always red
[Music]
so what's the problem here if i go to
the get marked locations
and if i bring this color here
okay this is
not always red
not always
i mean sometimes it doesn't look red
at all
i think
some problem can be with the threshold
that i'm using maybe i could make it a
bit higher but i think that if it's too
high then maybe my shirt will look blue
or
let's try to go here
200 but
this really depends on the room
no something here is now turning
turning blue
how about without the headset
no some things there are just too much
so maybe this
needs to be something like that
it might be good enough if there would
not be these reflections there
so
i'm gonna do something about the lights
in this
um
okay and now i can't see very well
because i looked directly in the light
ah
going great
still waiting
ah good that time is ticking and i have
maybe
three hours left of available
time
i can use for this
i'm not gonna use anymore
okay getting a little better
so
i think some
it's better
this
detection seems to be
seems to be better
and if i'm hiding these blue things
then the sliders work again
so
of course um
i have to code now these things a little
bit differently so
i want to know where this is and where
this is
all right
so
[Music]
how do i do that
well
i'm really concerned first about this
bottom point so this is my most
important point there
and
i want to detect it first
so let's figure out how to get this
bottom point first
and
let's just
do here something like process
image and move the code there because it
starts to be horrible where it is at the
moment we may need to add some more
files here
uh actually i'm gonna
move these
to
camera
file since
that's where we initialize the camera
and it's close enough to
image processing
at the moment
so
function
process image
and the video and the camera context are
global
variables i think everything here should
still work now
yeah
so here this is just for debugging
so now the
markers here on the right are
not changing color
but if i put debug to true i will also
see point a there
but uh it's fine
and
this does change like that so
inside of the camera file
i'm going to
also here say
find
um get constellation so these are two
stars two points and there will be two
more here and probably one more here so
i'm gonna have a function that gets me
this constellation
from these
marked locations
so i
of course now there are many many
locations here that are making this red
point and
this one so they will need to be
averaged or something
but um
let's get them like this and say here
const constellations
constellation
or just points
is
get
those
things i don't know why i want to call
it like that technical term is
clustering but uh i'm not going to use
any clustering algorithm for this
i want it to be more reliable and
they tend to be either
slow or too complicated or
random
in some cases
so i want to detect first this point
with this get constellation function
and
then i will want to draw them
so
we'll get to that but inside of this get
constellation function
i want to say
get the point with the minimum
y value so i think the point with the
minimum y value must be inside of this
one
here
in this region
many points here
so let's say
um
meanwhile point is
find the point
so that
this location or this point that we are
inspecting
this is a vector now so the
second component is the y
is equal to
math
the
maximum actually because y grows
downwards on the computer so maximum
um
of the y values
of the locations so i'm going to say
here
locations
map
like this so this is going to give me an
array this map here is going to give me
an array of all the y values then the
max is going to be the maximum of those
y values and here we're going to find
the point with the maximum of the y
values
so let's leave this here
and
now
let's return it for now
just one point
okay
and
this is just one point now
and um
we were using something to draw this a
point previously so um
i don't know where that is it's in the
avatar
draw head
this one the draw point
so i want this to happen now in the
on the camera screen there
but it may not be very visible
because here there's some scaling
happening and here there's not
let's just see what happens so
drop point
it's some utility function
oh my the canvas is not even specified
so ctx and let me change this inside of
the avatar give it the ctx here and
we're not really using it anywhere so
that's good
now here
um
cam
ctx
and uh
let's call this point now
m
point
so the one we are getting the bottom
point from here
this should be with x and y
it's undefined
really how is that possible
because there must be some points there
to have some mistake here let me just
first
log this part
okay so these look like some y values
indeed
oh
this is an array here
it's an array and
max doesn't work with array it works
with
many parameter values so i have to
spread that right there
okay
no error at least
but
oh i
should probably include this doctype
here
so this thing doesn't appear anymore
okay
i think the point that we are displaying
is
too small
so when we draw the point here i'm gonna
have to give it some big radius
bigger radius
something is there now but uh what
happened to everything else
what happened
did that in this dog type do something
to my css
what
really
how did that happen
okay
so
now the point is actually here this
small m there
so um
it's not exactly in the middle of all
these red points here at the bottom
but maybe we'll get to that
first i wanted to have this
m point there
and uh i need to draw this a little bit
bigger it's just too small so um
going back to the camera
and now i think it's too big because if
i'm gonna have many small ones there
yeah it's good a little bit fidgeting
like that but it's it's fine
so
this is just the one point the minimum y
point
now i'm gonna
take the nose point
so
um
to get the point on the nose i'm
basically gonna get
the farthest away point from m
and i'm doing that
i i think i can also get the one with
the smallest
y
but i'm gonna use this furthest away
from trick later so let's do that
i will say
let i
like that
i teach it better in this way
so going through all the locations i'm
going to calculate
the distance between
locations of i
and
the min y
point which is actually the max y point
because
y grows downwards
so
yeah max
so
the distance from
each point to that one and i'm going to
take the maximum so
i'm going to say
nose
point
is going to be
just some location
like that
and
and that and here
if distance is more than max distance
then max distance is going to be
distance and
nose point will be updated to be
the location of i something like this so
just getting the maximum
the furthest away point from
this end point
and now i have two points that i want to
return so i'm going to call this chest
and max y point
and
nose
[Music]
nose point
i think i should call this one
chest
point
it's clear that it's the max y from this
line of code there
so
now i have two things that i'm returning
and i have here points
and um
or i could have
destructuring here like nose and chest
and now i can say draw the
nose point
let's call it
n actually for nose
and the other one which is m here let's
call it
c for chest
okay
okay so i have the nose and i have the
chest
and it seems to be quite quite reliable
sometimes problems because of this
shininess
i couldn't do everything i wanted with
the lights because
the window is also there and it's too
complicated
but
this is something that kind of works now
at least
a little bit
and it can be much better in better room
conditions or with different types of
markers here that don't
shine because
there are materials that don't shine out
there and
i just happen to have a crappy one
does this mask
work as blue if i change the color
now
i think this is okay for this demo
okay so chest point nosepoint
what do we do with them
well
um
i need to know some
i need to calibrate the system
so i'm going to add here a button that
says
calibrate
and
html
like that
and
when we press on this
calibrate light
i wonder if this is how you write
calibrate
anyway i don't use internet so
i can't check
so calibrate
um
it should go also in the camera for now
at least
so what happens now here is that
i want to
i really want to keep these as a global
variable so
let's call these
something like that
and now that and here i can still
destructure so
okay
and when i calibrate i'm going to
let's just log this
like that
okay so i have the nose and the chest
coordinates
when calibrated
so what i'm going to do is
when i press calibrate i'm going to make
a copy
of these
points
yeah i will say here
the reference location so
the reference
um
is going to be the one when you press
the calibrate and then we're going to
calculate relative to those somehow
so
constellation points
reference is equal to
nose is gonna be
like that
and
the chest
is gonna be like that so
now i can log it after that
and if i'm gonna press calibrate i'm
gonna get
the nose and the reference
and if i move now
a little bit and i check constellation
points like this i should get
i'm losing them
yeah i'm losing them i'm replacing them
here
so let's add the code as before
like this
and now
i just write here constellation points
nose is equal to nose
i think this is going to work
yeah now they're equal but if i'm moving
and i'm
debugging
they are not equal anymore
so relative to this
uh change so depending on this change
somehow
because i need to know
how far
is n from c to be able to do the head
movement like this properly
so now
i don't need this log anymore i believe
they are working
based on this calibration
here
i want to
based on nose and chest now
and the reference nose and
and chest i'm going to figure out
something here so let's get the distance
between nose and chest so
distance between nose and chest
let's just call this d1
and
d2 is going to be the distance between
the ref
the constellation points
ref nose
and constellation points
ref chest
so these are the
other values when we press the calibrate
button
so two distances here so now um
depending on how much these distances
change if if d2 is exactly equal to d1
then
the head is gonna stand stand still but
if d1 is going to be bigger it means the
head should go up
so
d1 minus d2 and then we figure out some
kind of
scalar for that
so i'm going to say here
d1 minus d2
the difference on y so this is d1 minus
d2
and that's going to be the value for
this
and i'm not gonna
change x anymore i'm just debugging now
so the head can't move
all right we need to have a reference
so without pressing calibrate nothing
happens
and now if i calibrate
very interesting
[Music]
very interesting
yep
way too much
we divide by the
height
and i think i messed something up here
it should be d1 d2 minus d1
calibrate first
okay but i want more stronger than that
so let's scale this by something let's
say
five times what it's doing at the moment
i press calibrate
okay
and now horizontally nothing happens but
it's easy i think let's just call this y
one and y two
uh
they mean some distances um
to the
nose
or no they were the distances yes sorry
but horizontally we need something
similar so
we need we don't use actually the
reference anymore
i just want to know if n is on the left
or on the right of this c right here
so
yeah
so i'm going to say
diff
x
is
nose
x minus chest x
and also i'm going to divide this by
i want to divide by this d1 actually
let's see
i
i'm starting to get tired and i can't
really explain anymore why i think some
of these some of these things work
but
basically the distance
this distance i want to use somehow for
normalizing
and
this should be here and this code should
work now
i mean should be active
okay very interesting
very interesting
something is strange
oh these
don't have x and y they have
zero and one
i
i hope
uh
and i'm interested in x so zero for both
of them
nice i like it
maybe multiply this by two
okay
calibrate
yeah
this starts to feel awesome i i'm really
excited about this
sometimes crazy stuff happens like if a
point disappears
but that's just how it is i'm not i
don't even know what to do about things
like that
it will work in very good lighting
conditions even better than this room
and um
if these things don't
don't shine i think this room is quite
good actually but the the material on
these things is not great
[Music]
so some crazy stuff can happen
when i'm testing but
and there's a fidgeting here you can see
the head somehow fidgeting all the time
because
i'm not actually detecting
uh very well
the center of all the blue points there
so i would like to do that
eventually
let's fine-tune this later so
i want now to detect
points
on the side of the mouth
no this point on the bottom of the mouth
next
no the sides of the mouth so i need to
cut some more of this
tape
and
i'm going to do it in a smarter way now
i'm
going to actually
peel the outer layer i can't draw on the
outer layer because it's too slippery
and the color just leaves off
it's this kind of wax paper
so i'm gonna
draw here blue on one side
for
three more points
like that
and now i just cut these
always important to
pay attention to what you're doing
normal things that what you're doing
and see what can be improved because if
you keep doing
something in a
bad way like how i drew these the first
time then you never become better at
things
[Music]
i don't think it will stay there
stays on my lip
not where i want it to be
i want it to be
here on the side
nope
i'm in trouble
this bottom part of the lip is fine
so at least i can do that
it's not the best but
it stays here i think
the other ones i really don't know what
to do about them
so
one here for opening the mouth it's
definitely possible but i can't open the
mouth
sideways which is
hello
hello
hello
hello
maybe the points here
hello
hello
they are too much
um how to say
now they aren't on the side of the face
and they are really getting light from
the window and it's a problem there
um it really needs to be here
maybe i can somehow wrap it around my
beard
is this
hmm
i don't know how reliable this is
because from the front you just don't
see it now
or
maybe something
so somehow wrapping it around the beard
and
inwards at the same time
yeah hard to describe what i'm doing i
don't know
how to say it
but
i might be able to pull this off let's
see
hmm
is it getting anything
[Music]
maybe on the outside
no
okay
ow
horrible
i'm gonna have to make new ones
i think that attaching it to the beard
like that works
i think attaching it to the beard
does something
but then i have to
use two types of tapes so
one of it is gonna be just to
attach to the beard
so i'm gonna
put it
just here like that
i think
and
yeah
something like that and the next one is
going to this normal blue thing which i
have to do again
and attach it
what
oh great yeah new point coming in
somewhere
something like that
it's not very
good
but
i think it will work i think something
will work and i probably look horrible
and can i still drink
yeah
so we have two points and now i want to
get this let's just call it left right
and
l
r
b
so that's how these points are going to
be called
l r and b
and um
let's get point
l
l or r it uh it doesn't matter they are
kind of the same thing and the property
of that will be that
the
sum of distance from this one to this
and to this
must be maximum so the farthest away
point from here
is going to be that point that has the
biggest possible distance to n and c
so
let's call that point
l
l point
and say that it's the location of zero
as before
i'm going to copy this code
and
[Music]
a new max distance i'm just going to
reinitialize it with zero
and the distance is going to be the
distance to the chest point
plus the distance to the nose point
so
yeah
then
l point is going to be the new one
and let's just call it
l
l point
like this
so now with our constellations here
i just want to draw it
so l of 0 l of 1 and let's just call it
l
i need to
destructure it here as well
okay so l is a point
and it's either here
or
in the other place
i could force it to be one or the other
but
for now it doesn't i will do it later
let's get r also
so r is going to be
if you know l like if l is this r is
going to be the point that is the
furthest away from all the other ones
so i'm going to go here and say
r
like that
and
i copied this
with r point
and here i'm gonna also add the distance
to
l
white let me write these distance
sums one under the other so that it's
more visible what is happening here
and uh
this is gonna be our point
okay
no
it's not good
something is not good so first problem
is
when i'm drawing them this should be r
here
okay
okay
so
why it doesn't work so i'm having now
l here
okay and when
or
l here and when air l is here r is for
some reason there
next to c
because it prefers the distance there so
l and n distance to l and distance to n
is so far away
uh
yeah
that it's better to be down there than
here these will be short and only one
long so
i think maybe trying instead of a sum
doing a product there
is going to emphasize that even more
so let's see
okay so
now
this system seems to work
not big difference in l and r but
it is what it is
uh with different kind of markers it can
be even better and
probably if i get closer or let's see
later
the last one
just the same thing again the point that
is furthest away from all other points
so
i'm going to call that
b for
bottom of the of the mouth
let's have
b
b
b
b
b point
b point
b b
also the distance to r there
okay
not good
not good so
yeah again it's better to have a
position like that
i think what i'm going to do because the
chest point here is so low
and it's such a big problem either move
the point upwards a little bit so if
this point here
would be
no that's not helping much
let's put the weight on this chest point
make it smaller
no that's not the problem the problem is
that b is such a great place for being
far away from all the other ones
so maybe we
divide by the distance to the chest
point
no
so i want a point that is
far enough from
n l and r
but if you get too close to that point
it's bad
uh no
i think that i i had this
the other way around
what if i use here the minimum distance
the minimum distance
to rl uh
n and b
so minimum distance
if
distance is less than the
minimum
distance
then the minimum distance is updated
like
no
because now it's going to choose a point
that is it's exactly zero
how about
with the previous addition from before
huh
and how about squaring these
so squaring the distance
these individual distances
no why does it go there where
oh i'm looking for
a minimum distance but this is a very
small one to begin with
okay now it works i think many of the
others would have worked as well
too many details to start to explain
but
basically b is quite close to the center
of mass of all the other points so i
used it
in that way
this definition here with the sum of
squared distances is it's there now and
i can do a check here that if um
l point
x
i mean
zero is greater than our point
of zero
then swap these
i think i can do
something like this in javascript maybe
okay now l r are proper n is proper b is
proper c is proper everything is fine
but um
and of course if i calibrate
head still moves like this but the other
things are not
not appearing anywhere
so
what will happen next
is uh
is is
let's just put here in the calibration
in the reference points i'm going to put
also
l
r and b
that's the first thing
and now um
let's calculate
a distance between b and n so b and n
it's going to give us a distance for how
the mouth is opening so b goes down and
and always stays where the nose is i
can't move my nose
so
let's say
bn1 is going to be distance
from
nose to b
and bn2 is going to be a distance from
uh
let's just say here ref is
equal to that so that i don't write this
everywhere it's just horrible
okay so ref
knows
ref b
so
b and if
y is going to be equal to
b n one
minus b and two
probably like that
i
i don't want to think about it anymore
if it's not one it's going to be the
other
and this difference is going to be
divided by
wait
d1 let's keep the same logic and see
what happens
so with this bndiff i'm gonna say update
mouth
with um
value and
y
okay
so
let's try calibrate
everything broke
ref nose and ref b
oh
the constellation points are missing the
other ones
okay
calibrate
opposite
so
needs to be opposite and needs to be
multiplied by something more so i had it
right in the first time and let's
multiply this by five or something
calibrate
hello
hello
hello
hi
hi hi
hi
hello i think this can be even
six but i'm gonna try with seven
hello
hello
hi hello hello
l and r points are not really moving
i'm not using them yet but
nothing seems to happen at least not yet
this fidgeting is what i'm gonna fix
next so what i'm gonna do
is um
i really like it i
i did something really great i'm happy
with this
so um
the fidgeting i'm gonna take
an average of the points i'm gonna
average the points in their neighborhood
here
somehow
and replace
lrb and
nose and chest
with the actual average there so that
they don't jump around so much
and then this animation will be also
smoother on the left it's not good as it
is
so let's try that
next
now that we have all of those points
there
i'm going to go through
let's create sets of points that are
closer to n to l to b to air and to c
so i'm going to call these
n set
like this
c set
b
set
lsat
r set
and now i'm going to loop
through all of the points
and i'm going to say
to calculate
five distances is
n this is going to be distance from
logs of i to
a
nose
point
and the others will be like
same
c distance
b distance
l distance r distance
and this is gonna be
chest
point
this is gonna be
b point
l point
and r point
and now i want to put these in the set
where the distance is the minimum
so let's
get the mean
uh
is going to be math dot min of endist
seedist be this
eldest
this like that
and
i'm going to say
if
mean this
is going to be equal to
and this then
and set push
locks of i
and else
if mindist is
seedist
then c set is going to be
logs of i
then b
this here
b set is going to be log getting logs of
i
l
l set
r
r set
yeah
so now i have sets of points
for each of those
things so these points are going to be
nearest to
the ones that are marked on with the
letters on the camera
but um
but now i can calculate the average of
each of those and replace
each of those points like nose point
chest point b point and so on so
nose point
is going to be
average of
n set
chest point
b point
l point and r point
so r set
l
set b set
c set
ends
might be confusing what i'm doing now
but
look at the points now and look at this
fidgeting on the right
and it should be gone when i refresh if
i didn't make any errors
errors
okay
chest point
is const
okay calibrate
much more stable
so i'm gonna actually have a tutorial
someday about this lightsaber effect and
i will teach better there what i did
here with the averaging so
i don't know if it's already out when
you're watching this or if it's coming
but
we did it
i i averaged the points and now they
became stable because they are not
represented anymore by one single point
but by many points
many points
averaged together and
they are not fidgeting so much
yeah this is great wow i'm really happy
with that character moving there
when the points are not blocked
otherwise it's horrible
okay
let's try also these side points this
l and r
maybe they work who knows
so
i'm gonna copy this code
like this and say
l r diff with dx
lr1
lr2
lrdf
x
is gonna be lr1 minus lr2 divided by d1
multiplied by something
and lr diff
x there
so let's see
calibrate i'm looking straight at the
camera
hey
it kind of works
hello
hello wow
wow this works um how about if you put
bigger value here
nine
not 79.
okay calibrate
hello
hello
hello i am raduz avatar
hello i'm radus avatar
maybe with the mouth it would look even
better
let's see if i redesign it to have a
mouth in the end
i think i need a
few minutes break and then i have about
one and a half
hours
left to do this so i'm gonna do
i'm gonna
during my break i think i'm gonna record
myself saying something with these
things on my face
so that i can play with this method
also without these things on my face
i mean to play with this
thing
so i will record myself saying something
and
when we come back
uh
when i come back
i will
make this work with the camera or only
with the sliders
or with the video that i'm going to
record
and
i like it
a lot
and
then fine tuning drawing these to look
like hair kind of like in the original
drawing
and these strings here
they are small minor it's much more
interesting what happens up here now but
i like them
great so
i will take a 5-10 minutes break and
record also something meanwhile
okay i'm back and
i recorded a short video to test this i
don't know if it works yet but i added
it here as this
mp4
file in the folder
and i think it's really easy to test
here i just have to put
something like
and before of course it's still gonna
initialize the webcam and and do
whatever
but uh
it's
gonna replace the data
uh from the webcam with the
source coming from that video
let's see if it works
it crashed
but um it's talking there something and
that's me from the video it crashed
because of a
course
so it's trying to load the file from the
computer and uh do some processing with
it like image processing and the browser
doesn't like that
um
i think i need to
make this into a server
so
let me go to
show the status bar
in this visual studio code and i have
this live server
extension
allow
access
and
and and
now instead of going to this
location i'm just going to put here
the localhost
ip address and
this 5500 port
hi i am
okay
one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten there were some problems there
with um
with some of those things disappearing
sometimes
but
let's
refresh and press to calibrate also
quickly somehow
or i don't know
um i want this to actually
calibrate here
wow every time i'm
saving something it's updating there the
server works differently
testing one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
yeah um
this calibrate can't be called there yet
because the image processing hasn't
happened yet
so
i'm gonna take it out
i'm also going to disable the sound here
four
five
six
seven eight
nine
ten
hi i am radus avatar
testing
one
two
three
four five
six
seven
eight
hi i am radhu zabatar
testing one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
not very bad not very bad i like it um
let me disable the sound because this is
disturbing every time i i change
something in the files this is uh
updating in the browser and talking
i can't concentrate when he's talking
when i'm talking there like that
some
uh
maybe that
seems to work so the voice is not there
anymore so there is some small problem
with the
mouth here
and also
here
and
i wonder if i can
hmm
work with the different thresholds that
are better so that it works for all the
cases let's say
195.
was it perfect
there was a little bit of a jumpiness
but not much
uh only if you look on the right side
then this b was jumping at some point
but only a little bit the mouth looked
okay i think
yeah
okay i think this is just good
so
i have a demo now as well
i can put this on my website
and show it to the judges later
otherwise it's very hard for somebody to
test this application of course you
could do something with these sliders
but
it's not as great as when you see it in
action and people won't put these things
on their face or wouldn't know how to do
it unless they see some example like
this
so i'm happy i did that
let's change the input somehow based on
if you want to use the sliders or this
video or your own webcam
so
in index.html
i'm going to
go
and say
here
now where do i want to put this
selection for the input
um
i think the sliders shouldn't even
appear
so sliders should actually be called
side
panel
and
here
these are the sliders now
and the sliders can be
invisible
i mean not added to the dom
if the video is playing and in the
beginning and i want the video to be
playing in the beginning
but i don't necessarily want the camera
access because people don't like to
share their cameras and website usually
so also the calibrate button not needed
if the video is there
so
okay
and
now we can add this kind of
select
component
let's call it
input
and
id of input
and now i'm gonna give it
some options inside so option
with the value of
video
video
and
then
the other ones are just going to be
camera and
sliders
okay
great
so these will be
here it needs a label
let's give it also
on a new line
and
okay
here
okay
so
inside of this camera.js file
i think i'm going to just initialize the
video with element here at the top like
this
and
i'm actually gonna
copy this
here
this navigator media devices blah blah
blah
this should be inside the function
called
initialize camera
and we only call that when we change
that selection
i think
and what will happen then is
so by default the page should load the
video first
okay it wants some kind of a
start button or something
let's add here
or i don't know
now it worked
so it begins with the video
or no maybe it will want us to do that
so let's just put here a button that
calls
a button that says
start
like this and the start function
let's just go to the camera for now and
say here
start
something is wrong there
this needs to be here
it changes the size already now
now start
and it begins and i think that it won't
complain anymore about
problems
so
it starts that but if we change this to
the camera i want to do initialize
camera and then i don't want to do this
anymore
i do want to say that the source object
is going to be the data from there
or maybe i do want to do this because
maybe the
yeah
i'm gonna create a new video i'm gonna
set its
source object like that
not like this
because the camera your camera might be
different than my camera when i recorded
the video and so on
so
yeah
so this start here should be start
video maybe let's see
so when i refresh and i press start this
is going to start
and
it's great i like it
and
when i change to camera or sliders some
things should happen so
let's make here an unchanged
okay so here we have camera sliders
video
and
switch
info dot value
if we have
video
then what happens
um
let me close many of these things from
here
so
i think i want to have this one like
that
and i actually
think i it should be
re-initialized here so let's just have
it null in the beginning
re-initializing it like that
this volume
i should remember to put it back to
maximum
start
break
and now if this is a camera
then
we are gonna do
initialize camera
okay
so start the video
video starts
if i change this to camera
it works but
i think i'm in different positions and
it's not calibrated or something
video is great
yeah something is wrong i oh this
headset was making some bad
colors i think
okay
now it's good
so video seems to work
it starts it's doing some different
things there
camera
okay let's put also the video with the
volume to one i'm
i mean
hide this
because i wonder if the video plays in
the background
so the video is playing in the
background and i think we should do
video stop
before
starting something else
if possible
testing one
two
three
four
five
seven
eight
nine
ten
hi i am
testing
okay
i want to start in the beginning to just
start the video without the option to
give the input
so i'm gonna
remove the input from there
just in the beginning so i'm gonna say
here
input display none
input
container
display none
and the input container will be inside
of this thing
so
okay and these line breaks i think
should be also inside there
more line breaks here maybe inside this
video output
okay so now you just have the option to
press start there
hi i am
testing one
so when we press the start
i'm gonna make this input
up here
and this start button should disappear
because we don't need to press
start anymore i think
okay
so now we have the video we change to
the camera
calibrate button should be there with
the camera
so
we need that
everybody's going to have different
markers on their face and if they ever
try this
i will
so calibrate button
no need to calibrate with the video it's
just confusing it
does the calibration it should do the
calibration automatically let's put here
on the first frame
so auto calibrate set to true
so on the first frame
when there is no constellation points
there
we calibrate
yes
yeah i think this is good
um
but i don't want auto calibration for
the camera because
people need to see themselves first
so now it doesn't work but if i press
calibrate
hello
hey
hello
hello
la la la la la la
[Laughter]
oh
something was happening with this point
okay this is very funny
uh come on a little more energy i need
more energy
video
yeah it starts well and it auto
calibrates itself on the first frame
there
camera
calibrate
hello hahaha
great
and the sliders doesn't do anything yet
let's put this to be
initialize video
initialize camera initialize sliders
and now in the beginning the
start button is going to be
initialize video
[Music]
yeah
and the sliders
here so
right
so initialize sliders
this should be in something like a
control panel let's make
control panel js and just move some
functions there
like that
and from here
so they initialize sliders it's going to
be something like
like what
we have the sliders here that need to be
turned on
we want the video output to be turned
off
so
sliders with output
i'm getting some messages
i have to check
yeah
okay
so the output none
and
make sure that the sliders are off in
both of those cases
so start the video
then they can change the camera for
example but nothing but really will
really happen here unless they do
something serious like this
um
what happens if they press calibrate now
so somehow with a
marker like this
funny things happen
very funny things happen you really need
to have
points on your face like i have
and then it works
okay
sliders
okay
uh
no not okay
the video needs
to be not
active anymore
[Music]
maybe this video pause is enough
and
constellation points has to be set to
nothing
let's see if now it's different
so video is there
camera is there calibrate
okay
for me
seems to work i want a
line break between the after the sliders
why don't they work
i think the video is still there
so in the camera we have process image
this is going to happen all the time
here
video
it needs to be
put to null we need to put it to null
here
that will make the sliders activate
yes
okay great um
but now we are gonna work with this
video i think and maybe with the camera
if these things still stay on my face
calibrate
would be good to have some kind of
some kind of
instructions here what to do
maybe
start is not defined oh
where's the video
getting tired
this is some common behavior it should
be
grouped together
calibrate below the camera i think below
the input i'm gonna
move that button there
it's better like that
okay good
we have something
we have something that works here
and even with this video i like it
problem now is just that
uh
these styles are horrible this hair
needs to look like hair
and i
still need some energy and i don't know
how to get it
but uh
come on it's a little bit more effort
[Music]
[Applause]
i think
i can do something
[Applause]
maybe
i like the hair
i really like the hair
what's wrong with this c now it's
getting color from the
it's getting glare from the light
i don't think i can do much about the
lights to make it better but
this is really great i'm really happy
with
what i have done
and for the hair
let's do this
so
i want to connect now this point to this
point
may be influenced by this point
let's do that so
move to here
line to here curve to
this place and see what happens
so inside of the avatar
actually in the hair
okay head is something that is empty
i don't think we use head anywhere
i remove this head now
so here uh
not in the hair but
inside avatar because this is where we
define these
front hairs
so what i'm gonna do now is
here where we are drawing
that's not gonna be
used anymore at the end
um
and i'm gonna
say
draw
front
hair a function on the
ctx
actually a method here
draw front here like this
and i would say
begin path
move to
this front hair
of
zero
so this is going to be now
the first pendulum
particles of zero
and these are
arrays so i can
do
spreading here
location
okay
and
line two
particle 2 location so this is gonna
draw
a line let's make ctx stroke and let's
make this one
yellow
so this line right here that you can see
in yellow
here
so now let's try ctx
quadratic
curve
two
and it's gonna go to
the second hair
the base of the
second hair
with the second hair
control point from
the middle
yes and here
comma
so this is what i'm getting
now
my drawing here okay it's kind of like
in reverse actually
the
curves are in reverse here
mm-hmm
so i should use this as the control
point
uh
no problem
okay something like that
and i will do the same thing
for the other
one
hmm
looks nice
i would like to have another hair
somewhere on the left here that i won't
draw but
it will affect this other hair and the
other things
so let's actually do that have another
pendulum
in
even more to the left here like
three two
oh this is the back here
okay that's good
or even 41.
it doesn't matter if it's outside
so what i will do now is uh
that here
strand here is not going to be
drawn so
i'm gonna
go it's just gonna influence the others
it's crazy
uh
what i'm doing
so then i'm actually gonna start at the
first hair here
and
continue to do as previously but now
instead of this line 2 i would like to
have it influenced by this point
so this is not straight anymore so i'm
going to
replace that line too with another
quadratic curve
and
end
location will be that
but
this will be
that
what
no line to
yeah yeah this is what i want
that's what i want
okay
so now that i'm here i'm gonna
repeat the same thing
but
here i'm gonna have one here i'm gonna
have two
here i'm gonna have two and here i'm
gonna have three
i like that great
and uh
now
i really feel like i want this to be
more in the middle more on the left
so this is now
front here of three
zero one two three
maybe
yeah
and
maybe this also a little bit to the left
actually this one also a little bit to
the top
and the next one a little bit to the
left
and i would like
actually the first one
to be even more to the left
but i don't care that it's outside like
that
and
maybe even more
and the first one here
maybe 31
okay and i will need another one at the
end
so
like that for the influence of this last
strand so now i'm going to do a little
bit of things in reverse it's going to
change the direction
let's add one more strand there
two on the left and three on the
right
i want there are too many here in this
original one i don't want to waste time
on that now
so uh
i want one more strand so let's
group these
more
so this goes even more to the left maybe
1 5
28
and another one here
thirty
two
no
forty
[Music]
37
26
13.
something like that
so now going back to this place
let's do
third here
so from here we are actually gonna go
influenced by
four maybe
this is now three and this is four
now
this is five
no this is four
this is
five
yeah
okay now i got it
okay so now i have the third hair
and
fourth hair
five five
six
five
okay
fifth hair
six six
seven
six
something is not good
yeah the point that i'm using to
influence here i think this should be
four
now
no we're done we are done i forgot the
last one is just
to guide guide the things
so now that we have done all those
all these things
i think all i need to do is um
fill
not stroke
okay
and probably i want one more
line too and i'm gonna go in this middle
point right here
so that i will cover part of this bold
area
maybe that's enough let's see so
zero one two three
align to
[Music]
three particles of zero location
maybe it's enough i hope
and now
i don't want to draw
these
anymore
oh boy i look
bold
i
i think that's maybe a sign that i'm
becoming bold
uh
it's fine
yeah
uh let's see how it looks like
with the video
nice
okay
let's put the sliders on
okay
it's pretty okay
uh let me add back the
stroke and
i think this one is just too
much to the right
so
and this one
yeah like that
now when i'm actually drawing the hair
i could move this point
lower so that i don't look so bold let's
see
draw half here
topmost point okay
but um
what was this point here
i don't know
i think it's something on the side
the control point probably it's that one
or the outer one
right most point okay probably that one
wow i look so cool i don't know how i
did that
i like it
but i don't look like that
so it wasn't that point
i think it's
this point right here
so
okay
and let's disable now that
stroke from here the yellow line that i
don't want to see anymore
i think these control points here need
to be
i don't have hair that goes like that in
the
down there
yeah so this control point needs to be a
little bit lower
not that i think here i need
no
this is the outer control point okay
uh
oh yeah yeah yeah this one
it's okay
it's okay
i think the hair can be lower
the front hair can be lower
yeah
i like this it's better
it could have few more hairs i think but
it's not bad
it's not bad at all
hello
hello
hey
i think that the initial video is so
boring compared to what you can make it
do
let's
i i want to do the
hair in the back as well
and then these front things
so for the hair on the back i'm gonna do
similar tricks
and
i also want to have another one on the
left somewhere that is
outside the screen
or actually this might still be in the
screen
maybe something like that let's see
and a last one
okay
yeah maybe it's gonna be good
so i'm gonna do the same thing for
draw
back
here
so this
draw front here
does it have the same number of three
four five six seven eight one two three
four five six seven
it's almost the same
but
without the last one
this could be made definitely with the
loop and i wouldn't have to reuse that
but
somehow
i
like that i could style them
individually and if you would like one
of them to be a little bit different you
have control like this
so
i know this code could be
half this size but uh
i prefer to have this kind of
[Music]
control here
so now this front here
will be replaced with the back here
everywhere here so let's just do
okay something is happening
but uh
the drawing of the back here is now
on the front and i want it to be here
and okay
nice
um
okay
uh
needs to be bigger
needs to be bigger you don't see it well
enough so let me put here
nine nine nine
nine nine
nine
okay
and these ones on the side i think they
can be even more so
five and six
maybe
and these ones
not bad
oh
this is bad
so
i think the top part
of these can be
lower
hmm
too much
85
85
80.
and i think that
something is wrong here
i don't want it to move
maybe that much up and down
i don't know
somehow moving too much up and down
yeah i think i will just move
the outsides a little bit more in let's
say this is now
55 and this is 55
and
this can be 38 and
39
and i think that now shouldn't be the
problems anymore
they're okay
but uh that gravity thing
i think it's too much i want to see it
moving more so the gravity multiplier
not there
where is the multiplier
where am i calling that
oh in the double pendulum
oh yeah this update 2 method
this is the kind of thing that you
really forget
what it's doing
after some time
okay and i want the sides of the hair
here to be closer to the other one so
23
twenty
no
twenty eight
no
not the front here
back here
okay that one
oh
the side hairs are
too long now
these don't really matter
okay
[Music]
these ones are too far to the side
i like this shape more
these movements are just way too much
so
i think that what i want to do here is
put more emphasis on
initial location
why
oh no something is horribly wrong
this one maybe doesn't need that
okay
mm-hmm
okay
i want to move this point a little bit
to the left so
no
minus 36
and
36.
it's a little funny
i think that these sliders are just too
much
allowing too much freedom i'm gonna
put them even less because in the real
movement this never happens so i'm gonna
put here minus
three
on the y
plus three on the y
uh huh
and uh maybe even
two
two
and uh the step is gonna be
zero five
okay and i think this hair can be a
little bit more to the right
they are too close now
so let me go
back to the avatar and
try again
20 here
25.
okay
nice
so
one thing that could be tried is
actually
add one more hair on the front to
partially cover the years i think that
would be a great effect
uh i'm gonna still try to do that
and also limit this x a little bit i
think that
minus 0.4 and plus 0.4 is just enough
i mean
i'm cheating here not doing a real 3d
and
it can show
if i'm not paying attention
and of course people will notice it's
it's obviously a 2d animation there
and i think here it's just too much
movement still so
let me
or it's fine okay
i'm gonna try also something with the
front here
maybe i call it side hair
let's say side hair
and um
left
i'm just gonna copy these things
i need just three pendulums the one in
the middle is gonna do the actual
drawing
so this side here left
uh
update
and
draw
yeah so just copying the one that we had
previously
and
draw
side here
left
my this needs to be extracted into its
own function
and done some loop there
i'm too tired now
and it's gonna stay like this
so
[Music]
let's see if i have energy at some point
to fix the code
so
this is actually all we need there
yeah this is the side here
but now we need to tweak it a bit
so
the side here on the left
this point here
okay i'm i have to comment out this
front hair and this back hair it's
confusing too much
so why is it like that
side hair left
and also
these many things i don't want them
anymore
yeah
so
okay it's good but these things need to
be more to the left
i think
yeah let's put six here four here
something like that maybe
and up more up
okay something like that
so how does this look like with the
sliders
nice almost nice
too much to the left here
let's just put it so that
it's 50
40 to
31
okay
hmm
okay that's good i think
okay
so
i think we can do another one
on the other side
i'm just gonna put positive signs here
and hope for the best
side hair right
let's reactivate the back here
uh i'm gonna draw these if debug
front here
if debug
and
side hair
right
probably would have been much better to
write loops there
at least here i'm going to make draw
side here
function and here i'm going to say
side hair
left
and
i mean draw a side hair method
and write
just
object so
i will replace
this with the
argument and i don't need to copy those
i just can't concentrate anymore so it
has to be like that
okay
better maybe
let's put debug to false
oh
not like that
okay so those things are not visible
there and
i like it it's much more personal this
way
let's see calibrate
yeah
yeah
great i really like it
very nice
very nice
okay
so these things
uh
it's the last thing
and then i'm gonna take a break do
something else and come back in uh
maybe half hour or so and
see whatever quick polishing i can still
do
and i'm done with this so it was amazing
okay these things
i will make an option for the debug
there
oh yeah the horrible nose
i forgot it's so horrible
i don't need these
click listeners anymore
why should i remove this
probably it means this alpha thing
i don't need the image anymore
the reference image
yes
i can actually delete it from the
project here
and in the beginning i'm loading it
somewhere
image image
no need for image and i just need to
animate
yeah
good
fantastic
it's so great
why don't people do this
it's awesome
awesome
and now i'm thinking about that project
that we cut off the list with the
scanning website that scans your body
and so on it's not very complicated to
actually change this so that
you would do some face
profiling like how big are somebody's
eyebrows and what is the skin color and
i don't know things like that how far
apart the eyes are the big the nose is
and so on and then with that you could
change this avatar
automatically so
of course that one probably meant
something different like that the actual
textures and you
the
avatar you're making is pretty much
looking like you
but this is
in my opinion much better it's much more
creative
yeah okay those things i want to get
them done and then
i need to do something for
half an hour and then final
find fine tuning
probably debug button here if i if
people want to see what is happening
behind the scenes
right
[Music]
i said i'm doing those threads on the
shirt but i'm doing something else i'm
just cleaning up some of this code
okay much better
structure here
that thing
avatar
uh
okay five minutes
avatar
left string and right string so
update and draw so i don't want to draw
them
like this
i want to say
ctx
begin
path
ctx
field style
and i'm going to do an rgba
black with some transparency
like that
and probably
same for a stroke
style so what i want to do here is get
um
draw this as a circle
which is a dark transparent and i don't
need to define new colors
uh
pendulum
init location
x
y
a radius of something
full circle
and
no more drawing this left
left string like that
and the ctx fill
ctx stroke
too big
great
i would really like to do these ellipses
it's so easy to do but
no time now
circles are just too perfect eyes as
well
at least a little bit
oval-ish it's enough to make it so much
more organic
so
okay
this
this
that
okay both of these are there
and now
um
just a line too
something like that
but
thicker
i don't like that they're so straight
i'm gonna
do a quadratic
curve to
[Music]
going there
but
somehow
somehow i want the point here
anywhere really
yeah
um
that's fine
and um
same here
but the
other side
okay
somehow i would like the body to
move a bit more
and these things to move more
it's just too small movement i think for
them to be picked up
yeah
so maybe in the physics i'm gonna put
the
gravity less
no
no that's just fine they wouldn't swing
that much anyway
and again this is some kind of
very small
thing that i wanted there
no need to worry about so what i do want
to do is have this curvature a little
bit different so
plus
three
it's good and i want the thickness to be
more
ctx line width
uh
okay now they look better
right
way too much movement on the side i
don't like it i think it was
i find
more fine like that it needs to be
subtle i think it's the head that it's
doing the movement
and the side just a little bit
difference there
okay
one more test with the camera
calibrating
hello
[Music]
is this good
should i do more
great
[Laughter]
okay wow something crazy is happening
gwen
when not all points are recognized
wow this is fantastic i'm so happy i did
this
okay i'll take a
break and then
really wrap up all this page and and
that's it
i'm back
so
i still want to do a couple of things
um
add a debug
option
so that
for example when this video starts here
um
you don't see those things there
actually those need to be added
somewhere
um
let me see
this draw point so this is
if debug like that
it's
easy to do that part
but
um yeah
um but i want to have an option there
so
i need to use a
kind of a checkbox maybe
so
let's put
input
type
checkbox
okay and let's write here
debug
like this
and
yes
and give it an id
debug check like this
so
our debug value
no no no
i don't want it
it was fine like that
so on
change
toggle debug
this
and what will
happen now is that
okay so i compare it like that so i say
if this is
it was true or false so debug is equal
to
that
and it doesn't need to be a constant
anymore
so now there are a lot of points there
being visible
points in the video also
like control points
yes
but this jumps way too much somehow uh
yes
i think i just put this one at the very
top to avoid these kind of nasty
issues
okay
camera
calibrate
what
what is happening i need to see with the
debugging oh the headset is on
it's uh confusing it has some kind of
parts that reflect blue light
yeah
awesome
i like it
what happened
what happened
i didn't see what happened that
debugging was ah this
it's pointing upwards and the light is
reflecting
okay
okay yeah great no debug
awesome
great
okay
uh
video
this needs the sound to be on
let's remove also these debugging
statements
does that happen in the camera
no
index no we were in index how
where is this coming from control panel
oh okay i forgot we did that
i don't need that value anymore
put volume on
i mean we don't need this anymore so the
video does have volume
let's
check it out
hi i am
testing one
two
three
four
five
six
seven
eight
nine
ten
great
okay
the nose i still have a bit of energy
and time left
maybe 30 minutes max
so
let's try the nose
[Music]
nose
so i think that the tip there
i think we can do two curves one on each
side somehow
yeah
so
let me
adjust this a bit
so
somehow the nose would look
more
3d-ish more roundish
so i'm gonna
move to this is the top part i guess and
then there is the bottom part
yeah
so
this
i want to say
minus 0.1
now
0
three
okay
and um
[Music]
tip left so left tip tip l
like that
and another one on the right
with
plus that
so this is going i remove this thing
oh yeah two control points it was also
some idea
let's see
so with the
this one i'm gonna
do another
with the right
but i'm going to go back to this stop
point here
like that
not great but
let's see
so now uh
let's see how it looks like with the
sliders
huge nose there
i think
this can be one
yeah so now this other line
will depend on this offset i'm going to
make it transparent
so it's not important anymore because
the noise is defined by the outside line
so
the more
the line is on the outside
the more visibility it has so let's try
something like
ctx global alpha
ref.x offset
and
stroke
actually
i want to keep this top point there and
let's just put this bottom point also
0 and 0 33
um
actually i want this formula
hi i am
hi i am
hi
yeah i can't really explain what i'm
doing anymore
hi
hi
hi i am
oh
what is happening here
this is a number but this is some weird
thing
it's concatenating here some string
i don't know why it's doing that
hi i am
what is happening
i don't know but i think that if i'm
gonna
change this to do first the
audition hi hi
hi i am
no
hi i am
hi i am
okay
hi i am
i'm just gonna
comment out everything here at the
bottom focus on one side
so
negative values
no i don't want that um
minus 0.4 and i want
absolute value of this
hi i am
i don't know why it's not showing with a
different alpha
begin path move to
curve to
stroke and then the different global
alpha
what is happening here
how can this line appear here
uh
[Applause]
what is happening there
hi i am
what is happening
i really don't get what's going on now
and i don't have much time left
um
let me just undo everything i did here
and see if this weird behavior is still
happening
so
if i comment out this draw nose does it
do this strange thing
yes it does
and here if i say
doesn't make the nose red
i think it's something of a bug
and i'm not in the
i don't have enough energy now and brain
power to figure it out
let's see if two control points work
bezier
curve two
hi i am
a little bit more pointy there
hi
i don't want that
the opposite of that
hi i am
hi i am
hi i am
it's not going great
hi i am
why doesn't this work
i just undo everything
it feels like
it's against wanting its nose to be
changed
it doesn't want me to change its nose
and
i respect that
okay
i think this is it
it's
more than i thought i'm gonna do
i'm really curious what
samuel is gonna do
i have a feeling it might be more
impressive than what i did
because you can do so many great things
nowadays with
online resources and he's a very clever
guy
so
it's going to be exciting to find out
yeah but sliders work video
works
testing
camera works
hello
this is the last time i'm
talking now as the avatar
thanks for watching if you got to this
part
and
the code is not
horrible
but some parts of it could be better
much better
than
what they are
i'm really tired
and i'm gonna
call it a day because it's not yet night
it's just four in the afternoon
and i'm gonna go home
and rest
and
the weekend is coming
so
that's it thanks for watching
and
see you guys
[Laughter]
look at the hair look at the hair
it's great wow i like it
awesome
okay i'm gonna put one more thing here
instructions for what calibrate means
so in the control panel when we do the
video
hi i am radus avatar
testing one
hi i am
hi i am
hi i am
hi i am
hi i am
hi i am
hi i am
hi i am radus avatar
testing one
two
three
four
five
six
hi i am
why is calibrate there
hi i am
hi i am
hi i am radu zavantar
testing 1
hi i am
hi hi
hi i am
okay
okay
yeah
i'm gonna put this on my website and see
if the video loads
and that's pretty much it i might make a
simple preloader
if the website
if it doesn't load fast enough then
i'm gonna put their loading please wait
if
the video doesn't come immediately when
you press the start button
but that's a minor thing so
see you guys